ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर
लाइव लेट मी चेक
वंस एक सेकंड मैं चेक कर लेता हूं आप लोग
मुझे एक बार चैट में बता दीजिए प्लीज लेट
मी नो इन द चैट इफ आई एम
लाइव ओके
कैन
यू कैन यू सी कैन यू सी एवरीबॉडी
कैन यू हियर
मी आपको आवाज जा रही है क क्लियर आवाज जा
रही है एक बार जल्दी से बता दीजिए क्योंकि
यहां पर मुझे कुछ इशू लग रहा
है ओके तो यहां मेरे लाइव में शायद कुछ
गड़बड़ है यहां मुझे कुछ दिख नहीं रहा
था अभी आई थिंक ट्स
गुड चलिए ठीक
है ठीक है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है चलिए सो
मैं इधर चेक कर लेता हूं वेलकम एवरी बडी
टू द डे 52 ऑफ आवर बग
बाउंट फ्री एंड क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग इस
लेक्चर में इस क्लास के
फ्रीक्वेंसी में थोड़ा सा मतलब डिले हुआ
है थोड़ा काफी टाइम बाद हम मिल रहे हैं
एंड इट्स रियली रियली रियली गुड मतलब
अच्छा लग रहा है आप लोगों से जुड़ के फिर
से कई दिनों के बाद तो सभी को आ जाने देते
हैं एक बार एंड आई होप कि आप सबकी बग
बाउंट की जो जर्नी है वो कंटिन्यू आपने
रखी होगी एंड इससे आपको कोई फर्क नहीं
पड़ा होगा कि हमारी वीडियोस डिले हो रही
है या हमारी क्लासेस लेट हो रही है
क्योंकि ये आपका पैशन होना चाहिए बग
बाउंटीज करना एंड इट शुड बी योर ओन डिसीजन
एंड न पैशन
राइट ठीक
है कुछ तो गड़बड़ हो रही है आई
थिंक लेट मी रीलोड इट एक बार मैं रीलोड
करके चेक कर लेता हूं
इ आम टोटली इ इट टोटली फाइन
या जी
हां गा मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए क्योंकि
यहां
पर यहां पर डिले हो जा रहा है आप लोग यह
मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार चैट में जल्दी से
कि आप आपको क्लियर वीडियो दिख रही है क्या
विदाउट डिले
प्लीज लेट लेट मी
नो बट व्हाई इट्स नॉट प्लेइंग ऑन माय
मोबाइल डिवाइस सही से चल नहीं रही है मेरे
फोन पे वई
सो डिले आ रहा है ना हां हां हां
हां आई थिंक ू का कुछ इशू है लाइव
स्ट्रीमिंग को लेके मेरे ख्याल से
आज चलिए तब तक सभी लोग आ भी जाएंगे बट
लाइव स्ट्रीम को लेकर
मेरे ख्याल
से तो आज हम लाइव बग हंटिंग करेंगे एंड
आपको मैं तरीका बताऊंगा कैसे आप इजी बग्स
को फाइंड कर सकते हो वैलिड बग्स को ठीक है
जैसे बाकी जो रिसर्चस करते हैं आप देखते
होंगे लोग पोस्ट करते हैं
ओके आई थिंक नाउ इट्स
गुड आई डोंट नो
इस मेरे फोन पर चल नहीं रहा वीडियो यह
मुझे समझ नहीं आ रहा कि व्ट इ
हैपनिंग कुछ तो इशू है आई थिंक देर सम इशू
स्ट्रीम हेल्थ लेट म
सी इट्स
गुड ड नो दे सम इशू ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग टू एवरी बडी
गुड इवनिंग टू ल गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
सबको गुड इवनिंग मैं कुछ इशू है मैं चेक
कर लेता हूं एक बार क्या इशू आ रहा
है मैं एक बार चेक कर लेता हूं
अभी सही है आप लोगों को क्लियर आ रही है
एक बार बता द जल्दी
से एक ब बता द जल्दी से एवरीथिंग इ फाइन
इज एवरीथिंग
फाइन राइट
नाउ मैं मोबाइल पर भी चेक कर रहा
हूं ठीक है ठीक है चलिए
ओके सो लेट्स स्टार्ट गाइस एंड वेलकम टू द
डे 52 ऑफ बग बाउंट सीरीज एंड आज जो है हम
कवर करने वाले हैं लाइव बग बाउंट हम
बेसिकली करेंगे लाइव टारगेट पे करेंगे एंड
आपको ओवरव्यू भी दूंगा कि हम किस चीज के
ऊपर लाइफ टारगेट पे किस चीज के ऊपर हम काम
करने वाले हैं एंड दैट पर्टिकुलर वल्नरेबल
इज नोन एज ओपन रीडायरेक्ट अब जैसे मैं
आपको बताता हूं ओपन रीडायरेक्ट के ऊपर
लाइव हंटिंग करने का रीजन क्या है मैं
आपको क्लियर वो चीज समझा देता हूं पहले उस
रीजन ये है जब आप जाओगे ना
के एरर्स जो होते हैं वो होता है और उसी
में एक सबसे ज्यादा एक बहुत ही कॉमन वलने
एबिलिटी होता है ओपन रीडायरेक्ट वलने
एबिलिटी अब ओपन रीडायरेक्ट लेबिलिटी जो है
ना बहुत इजी होता है फाइंड करना हालांकि
जरूरी नहीं है कि आपको इजली मिल जाएगी बट
कुछ ऐसे एसेट्स को अगर आप टच कर पाते हैं
कुछ ऐसी लोकेशंस को आप लोकेशंस पे अगर आप
विजिट कर पाते हैं जो एगजैक्टली
अनटच है अभी तक एंड वहां आपको कहीं कुछ
पैरामीटर मिल जाता है जिस पे आप यूआरएल
रीडायरेक्शन कर सकते हैं व ओपन डायरेक्शन
वहां पे वने बिलिटी एजिस्ट करती है वो
आपको मिल सकती है तो आपके लिए एक यह हो
जाएगा लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट टाइप काइंड ऑफ
थिंग्स राइट कि आपने इजली कोई एक वलने
बिलिटी फाइंड कर ली और वो आपको रिवॉर्ड भी
करेगी लिटरली रिवॉर्ड करेगी चाहे वो
रिवॉर्ड छोटा हो बड़ा हो बट जब आपको एक
बाउंट लग जाती है तो आपके अंदर एक
कॉन्फिडेंस लेवल अलग ही आ जाता है तो वो
कॉन्फिडेंस के लिए मैं आपके लिए यह लाइव
हंटिंग सीरीज लेकर आया हूं फिलहाल के लिए
ओपन रीडायरेक्ट पे आई एम फाइन स यूज
बिल्कुल सही हूं मैं आई होप आपके
क्वेश्चंस पे आएंगे अ वेलकम ऑर्बिट एक्स
वाई जड अब यहां पे सबसे पहले क्वेश्चन पे
आने से पहले ना मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता
हूं सिंपल सा फंडा बता देता हूं ठीक है
यहां पे अ आप सबको अ जो भी वीडियोस होते
हैं हमारी क्लासेस के उसके डिस्क्रिप्शन
में जब आप जाओगे तो डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको
लिंक मिल जाएगी हमारे
यह कब शुरू हो गया यह कैसे आया ये
ट्रेनिंग कब आई या यह कोर्स फ्री वाला कब
से स्टार्ट होगा इसके रिसोर्स कहां
मिलेंगे वो सबका जो आंसर है ना अपडेट जो
है आपको हमारे
बाउटी हंटर्स का उसका भी लिंक मिलेगा उसको
भी जॉइन कर सकते हैं वहां डिस्कशन कर सकते
हैं बहुत सारे एस्पायरिंग बग हंटर्स आपको
वहां मिल जाएंगे यह हमारा कंपनी
linkedin.com
technical.com
teamlease.com सारी चीज आने वाले टाइम में
अभी आने वाली है तो आपको मजा आ जाएगा इन
चीजों को एक इन चीजों के बारे में जान के
और आज की जो ट्रेनिंग है वो बहुत ही खास
होने वाली है आज की जो क्लास है वह बहुत
खास होने वाली है खास इसलिए होने वाली है
क्योंकि हम आज की क्लास
में दो तीन चीजें करने वाले मेजर एक लाइव
बग बाउंट करेंगे रियल टारगेट्स पे ठीक है
दूसरा जो है हम समझेंगे कि क्यों एक जो जो
दूसरे बग हंटर्स है उनको बाउंट मिल जाती
है और आपको बाउंटीज नहीं मिल पाती है तो
आपको मेथड वो सिखाना वो तरीका सिखाना वो
मैं आपको बताऊंगा एंड तीसरा जो है वो कि
हम एआई का भी यूज करने वाले हैं साथ-साथ
मैं एआई का यूज करूंगा आर्टिफिशियल
इंटेलिजेंस जहां के हम हम यहां पे बात कर
रहे हैं चार जीपीटी की हम उसके यूज़
करेंगे और हम देखेंगे कि बग बाउंट हंटिंग
में चैट जीपीटी आपके लिए कितना बड़ा रोल
प्ले कर सकता है एंड आपको किसी की जरूरत
नहीं पड़ेगी लिटरली अगर आप चर जीपीटी को
अच्छे से यूज कर पा रहे हैं इस पर्टिकुलर
जर्नी में हर हर एक चीज का आंसर आपको देगा
हर चीज जो चाहिए आपको देगा आपको किसी तरह
की कोडिंग की नॉलेज की जरूरत नहीं है
लेकिन हां बेसिक आईडिया होगा तो समझ
पाएंगे कि एग्जैक्ट वो कोड कर क्या आ रहा
है एग्जैक्ट ये वन लाइनर करके आ रही है
बैश स्क्रिप्ट क्या कर पा रही है हम सबको
यूज करने वाले हर एक मेथड हर एक चीज आज
यूज कर जाएंगे एंड देखेंगे कि व्हाट वी
कैन डू इफ वी कैन फाइंड समथिंग
इंटरेस्टिंग राइट तो चलिए स्टार्ट करते
हैं सबसे पहले मैं अपना वीपीएस कनेक्ट कर
लेता हूं एंड उसी से हम सारी चीजें करेंगे
साथ में हम बब सूट को भी यूज करने वाले
हैं याद रखिएगा वी विल बी यूजिंग बब सूट
आल्सो राइट तो चलिए लेट मी स्टार्ट
फर्स्ट तो मैं यहां पर एक बार
जो लॉगिन है वह कर लेता
हूं ठीक है एंड देन गेट टू द मशीन एंड
लेट्स स्टार्ट लेट्स कनेक्ट टू द मशीन ठीक
है तो मैं मशीन से कनेक्ट कर लेता हूं
यहां
पे पासवर्ड मांग रहे है भैया हमारे तो हम
पासवर्ड को कॉपी कर लेते हैं राइट एंड
यहां पे पेस्ट करके एंटर कर देते हैं एंड
इट विल गेट कनेक्टेड टू आवर वीपीएस मशीन
तो हमारा
जो वीपीएस है उससे हमने कनेक्ट कर लिया है
नाउ वी आर गोइंग अगर फुल स्क्रीन मोड में
जाना हो तो वी कैन गो अदर वाइज हम इतना
इसको जूम कर सकते हैं ठीक है तो हम यहां
पे आ चुके हम बेसिकली एक मशीन में आ गए
टू यूज चैट जीपीटी एज आवर प्राइम टूल फॉर
एवरीथिंग इन टूडे सेशन लाइव हंटिंग करेंगे
तो ओबवियस सी बात है चाट जीपीटी का यूज हम
करने वाले हैं तो आई होप आपने सोशल हैंडल
वाली सारी चीजें जो है आपने देख ली होगी
तो मैं इसको कट कर देता हूं ताकि हमें
डिस्टरबेंस ना क्रिएट करें ये अब सबसे
पहला जो सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है वो है एक
टारगेट को ढूंढना एक टारगेट को ढूंढेंगे
टारगेट पे हंट करेंगे उसके पहले हम समझते
हैं कि हम ओपन रीडायरेक्शन की जिसकी बात
कर रहे हैं एगजैक्टली वो हो क्या है आपको
नहीं पता ओपन रीडायरेक्शन एक्चुअली होता
क्या है तो उसको हम देखेंगे पहले हम
समझेंगे व्हाट इज ओपन रीडायरेक्शन एंड देन
वी विल फॉर विविल प्रोसीड थ्रू द
प्रैक्टिकल सेशंस ओपन डायरेक्शन का मतलब
होता है अनवैलिडेटेड रीडायरेक्ट एंड
फॉरवर्ड आर पॉसिबल व्हेन अ वेब एप्लीकेशन
एक्सेप्ट अनट्रस्टेड इनपुट दैट कुड कॉज द
वेब एप्लीकेशन टू रीडायरेक्ट द रिक्वेस्ट
टू अ यूआरएल कंटेंड विद इन द अनट्रस्टेड
इनपुट मतलब कि एक ऐसा डायरेक्ट जो बिना
वैलिडेशन का हो रहा है अगर यह हो पा रहा
है एंड फॉरवर्ड हो पा रहा है वेब
एप्लीकेशन एक्सेप्ट करता है एक अनट्रस्टेड
इनपुट को अपने पास उस केस में इनडायरेक्ट
जो आपका जो वो पर्टिकुलर आपका यूआरएल है व
रीडायरेक्ट हो जाता है उस पर्टिकुलर
मलेशियन एज अ इनपुट अपने एक्सेप्ट कर रहा
होता है दिस इज वल्नरेबल
आप कोई भी वेब एप्लीकेशन हो वो बिना
वैलिडेशन के किसी भी तरह के किसी भी तरह
के इनपुट को यूजर इनपुट को एक्सेप्ट नहीं
करना चाहिए एंड यही सही तरीका है वेब
एप्लीकेशन के काम करने का ठीक
है नाउ ओपन रीडायरेक्ट जो है व कहां-कहां
प्रेजेंट हो सकते है इसका मतलब यह हुआ कि
किसी भी तरह का रीडायरेक्शन अगर हो रहा है
किसी वेब एप्लीकेशन पे जो कि बिना
वैलिडेशन के हो रहा है एंड वो किसी थर्ड
पार्टी एक यूआरएल पे रीडायरेक्ट हो रही है
किसी एक अलग लोकेशन पे रीडायरेक्ट हो जा
रही है तो उस केस में वहां पे हम बोल सकते
हैं कि देयर इज एन ओपन रीडायरेक्शन वनबिल
अब ये बहुत ईजी टू फाइंड है आपको जो
प्रैक्टिकल सिनेरियो दिखाऊंगा तो आपको
बहुत मजा आएगा लाइक ओपन डायरेक्शन फाइंड
करने में बहुत मजा आएगा लिटरली मैं बता
रहा हूं यू विल अगर आप सही से ट्राई करोगे
ना सही टारगेट के ऊपर तो डेफिनेटली आप में
से काफी लोग इस वनबिल को वैलिड वनबिल इसको
निकालेंगे एंड रिपोर्ट भी करेंगे एक चीज
बस ध्यान दीजिएगा कि ओपन रीडायरेक्शन
वनबिल कई ऐसे प्रोग्राम प्राम्स है जो
स्कोप में रखते हैं स्कोप बहुत सारे
प्रोग्राम्स के स्कोप में होता है ओपन
डायरेक्ट लेबिलिटी एंड बहुत सारे मेजर
प्रोग्राम्स एक्सेप्ट करते हैं ठीक है
कुछ-कुछ प्रोग्राम्स नहीं भी करते हैं तो
उनको आप छोड़ दीजिएगा उनका इन स्कोप आप
उनका पॉलिसी पढ़ लीजिएगा लेकिन मैक्सिमम
प्रोग्राम्स इसको एक्सेप्ट करती है ओपन
डायरेक्शन को क्योंकि इससे हम इंपैक्ट
क्या दिखा सकते हैं कि वी कैन बी
रीडायरेक्ट टू अ फिशिंग स्कैम वेबसाइट या
फिशिंग वेबसाइट एंड यूजर क्रेडेंशियल कैन
बी स्टोलेन यूजर के क्रेडेंशियल स्टोल किए
जा सकते हैं अब यह ज्यादा इसलिए खतरनाक हो
जाता है कि आपका जो मेन यूआरएल होता है वह
आपका मेन डोमेन ही होता है उसके अंदर से
रीडायरेक्शन होती है तो यूजर कंफ्यूज हो
जा यूजर को पता ही नहीं चलता है एगजैक्टली
यूआरएल पे दिखता ही नहीं है उसको देखेगा
ही नहीं कि अरे भैया कि हम कहां पे
एगजैक्टली लैंड कर रहे हैं उसको तो लग रहा
है चलो मैं facebook.com खोल रहा हूं और
facebook.com में ओपन डायरेक्शन वनबिल है
अब उस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल को कोई एक विक्टिम
खोल लेता है तो facebook.com क्वे मार्
url.com
उसको खोलता है तो evil.com पे चला जाता है
उसको तो लग रहा है मैं
facebook.com पे दैट केस ओपन रीडायरेक्शन
वलने बिलिटी एजिस्ट एंड मेलियस वेबसाइट पे
हम चले जाते हैं एज सिंपल एज दैट चलिए अब
ओपन रीडायरेक्ट जो है लॉगइन पेजेस पे हो
सकते हैं चेकआउट पेजेस पे हो सकते हैं
रजिस्टर पेजेस पे हो सकते हैं क्रिएट करना
है कोई पेज या कोई तरह का कुछ तो वो हो
सकता है पासवर्ड रिसेट पेज पे हो सकता है
एनी पेज ऑफि सम काइंड ऑफ रीडायरेक्शन किसी
भी तरह का कोई रीडायरेक्शन हो रहा है उस
पे भी हो सकता है ये ओपन इडायरेक्ट वले
एबिलिटीज अब यहां पे आपको वो तरीका समझना
है कि आपको क्या है ना एक पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट लेना है उसका कोई डोमेन सब डोमेन
कुछ भी लो और उसको पूरा पूरा ही उसको जो
है ना एकदम से टोटली घुस के उसके अंदर एंड
उसके हर पैरामीटर को टेस्ट आउट करना है अब
इसके लिए दो तरीके हैं मैनुअली कर लो या
ऑटोमेटेड कर लो मैनुअली करोगे तो एक-एक
पैरामीटर पे जाके देखोगे ऑटोमेशन के साथ
करोगे तो बब सूट का इंट्रूडर यूज करोगे या
टूल्स आते हैं बहुत सारे उनको यूज़ करोगे
एंड सारी चीजें होंगी तो हम सारे मेथड्स
को देखने वाले हैं लाइव हम इसको हंट करने
वाले हैं मैं उसके पहले थोड़ा समझा देता
हूं अब देखो एक सैंपल कोड है ये एक सैंपल
वल्नरेबल पीएचपी कोड है दिस इज अ सैंपल
वल्नरेबल पीएचपी कोड क्या है मैं आपको
यहां पे दिखा देता हूं यह कोड है यहां जो
पीएचपी से स्टार्ट हो रही है अब इस कोड
में क्या होता है रीडायरेक्ट यूआरएल के
अंदर में एक ले रहे हैं गेट एंड यूआरएल को
लिया जा रहा है एंड अब क्या होगा ये इसको
रीडायरेक्ट कर दे रहा है हेडर लोकेशन जो
है री डायरेक्ट यूआरएल के ऊपर रीडायरेक्ट
कर देना है
दैट्ची डायरेक्टली यूजर से इनपुट लिया और
उसको रीडायरेक्ट कर दिया दिस इज वल्नरेबल
अब इसको हम फिक्स कैसे कर सकते हैं इस
वल्नरेबल को हटा कैसे सकते हैं तो फिक्स
करने के लिए बहुत ही सिंपल बहुत ही सिंपल
तरीका है क्या तरीका है मैं आपको बता देता
हूं सबसे पहले हम एक काम कर सकते हैं वी
विल ओनली अलाउ ट्रस्टेड डोमेंस हम ऐसा भी
कर सकते हैं कि हम सिर्फ ट्रस्टेड डोमेंस
को अलाउ करें या तो हम रिलेटिव पार्ट्स को
यूज करें रिलेटिव पथ्स को ठीक है ना यानी
कि एक पार्ट ऑफ पेजेस को पा पार्ट ऑफ
लोकेशन को यूज करें उसी वेबसाइट के अंदर
में तो जब हम ट्रस्टेड वेबसाइट की बात
करते हैं ट्रस्टेड डोमेन की बात करते हैं
तो उस केस में क्या बात करते हैं किस
तरीके से कोड होता है यहां पे पीएचपी
स्टार्ट होता है अब यहां पे हम अलाउड
डोमेंस एक वेरिएबल के अंदर अलाउड डोमेंस
को डाल देते हैं कि भैया ये ये डोमेंस
अलाउड है हमारे पास अब रीडायरेक्ट यूआरएल
जो होगा वो कहां से होगा तो वो जो होगा
आपका पास यूआरएल जो होगा गेट यूआरएल पीएपी
यूआरएल होस्ट से होगा अब यहां से हम क्या
करेंगे अब यह देखिए इसमें हम क्या कर रहे
हैं यह देखिए यहां पे अलाउ डोमस में हमने
डाला यहां पे रीडायरेक्ट यूल में पास
यूआरएल कर दिया हमने एंड गेट यूआरएल करके
एंड जो भी यूआरएल बेसिकली हमने अलाउ किया
है हम उसकी सिर्फ उसकी बात कर रहे हैं अब
यहां पे एक कंडीशन इफ इन एरे यहां पे
रीडायरेक्ट यूआरएल इज़ अलाउड डोमस अब यहां
पे कंडीशन क्या डाला है हमने कि अगर
रीडायरेक्ट यूआरएल अलाउड डोमेन से है तो
तो फिर रीडायरेक्ट करना है ठीक है एल्स कर
देना है इनवैलिड रीडायरेक्ट मतलब अगर
अलाउड डोमेन में से कोई डोमेन है फिर तो
रीडायरेक्ट करना है नहीं तो हम उसको
रिजेक्ट कर देंगे
दैट्ची एटीआर पीओएस जो करके यहां पे है
स्ट्रिंग पीओएस जो है अगर यूआरएल में
स्लैश है यहां पे इ इक्वल टू इ 0 एंड एंड
एटीआर पीओएस रीडायरेक्ट यूआरएल जो है
एचटीटीपी है ये फॉल्स इ इक्वल टू इक्वल टू
फॉल्स है ठीक है तो अगर ऐसा है तो हेडर
में यहां पे रीडायरेक्ट कर देना है एल्स
यहां पे इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट डाल देना है अब
यहां पे ये जो फंक्शन है आपका एसटी आर
पीओएस जो फंक्शन है आपका ये फंक्शन पीएचपी
में क्या यूज में आता है यूज टू फाइंड द
पोजीशन जो स्ट्रिंग पोजीशन है बेसिकली
आपका पीओएस जो है आपका यह फाइंड द पोजीशन
ऑफ द फर्स्ट अरेंस ऑफ़ द सब स्ट्रिंग इन अ
स्ट्रिंग इट रिटर्न्स द इंडेक्स पोजीशन ऑफ
द सब स्ट्रिंग इफ फाउंड और फॉल्स इफ द सब
स्ट्रिंग डज नॉट एजिस्ट अब यहां पे हो
क्या रहा है इसका कमांड का मतलब क्या है
देख लो यहां पे चेक्स इफ द रीडायरेक्ट
यूआरएल स्टार्टस विद स्लैश यानी स्लैश से
स्टार्ट होगा रिलेटिव पाथ ठीक है रिलेटिव
पाथ रिलेटिव पाथ का मतलब क्या है मैं आपको
इसका एग्जांपल बता देता हूं जैसे यहां पे
मान लो fish.com है तो उसके बाद स्लैश आया
था अब स्लैश के बाद कुछ भी है जैसे
कांटेक्ट यहां पे स्लैश के बाद कांटेक्ट
है या स्लैश के बाद चलो यहां पे कॉन्टेक्ट
है तो यह जो पाथ है यह रिलेटिव उसी
वेबसाइट के इंटरनल पाथ पे ये जा रही है
राइट तो दिस इज द रिलेटिव पाथ तो उसी
रिलेटिव पाथ को यहां पे हमें डिनोट करना
है एंड हमें उसी को लेकर चलना है वी हैव
टू गो अहेड विद दैट पर्टिकुलर थिंग ओनली
क्योंकि हम जब उसको लेकर चल रहे हैं तो
उसी वेबसाइट के अंदर की चीज ही तो आ रही
है तो इसका मतलब है कि वह कहीं दूसरे
मेलिश वेबसाइट प
रीडायरेक्ट नहीं नहीं हो रही है गट यह
बताइए इतना समझ में आया सबको चैट में बता
द जल्दी से यहां तक समझ में आ रहा
आपको जल्दी
बताइए एवरीवन
प्लीज आई नीड एवरीवन टू रिप्लाई सभी
रिप्लाई करेंगे म आता
राइट
यस ठीक है ठीक है चलिए अब देखिए इसमें
कैसे होगा मैं आपको बता देता हूं आप लोगों
को वीडियो क्लियर आप लोग लाइव लाइव है ना
ऊपर में आप अपने व्यूअर पर क्लिक करके
लाइव पर क्लिक कर दीजिएगा ताकि आपको लाइव
रहे मतलब वो लाइव सेशन रहे लाइव आ रही है
ना आपको
ठीक
है चलिए तो यहां पे अभी आप देख सकते हैं
चेक इफ द रीडायरेक्ट यल स्टार्ट वि स्लश
एश्योर यूजर्स कैन बी रीडायरेक्टेड विद इन
द सेम वेबसाइट यानी सेम वेबसाइट के इंटरनल
पाथ प यूजर रीडायरेक्ट हो पा रहे हैं यह
इंश्योर करना है ठीक है अब देखिए जैसे अगर
यह एटीआर पोजीशन यहां पर अगर आप डैशबोर्ड
प होगा यह स्लश डैशबोर्ड आएगा कोई अगर
यूआरएल तो यह वैलिड हो जाएगा लेकिन अगर यह
एटीटीपी ड कॉलन कॉलन मतलब कॉलन एल कॉ आ
रहा है उस केस में इसको ये इनवैलिड बता
देगा और बोल देगा कि ये करेक्ट पाथ नहीं
है यानी कि करेक्ट रीडायरेक्ट नहीं है
इनवैलिड रीडायरेक्ट है तो इस तरीके से ये
चीजें काम करती है मुझे ये बताइए कांसेप्ट
क्लियर हो गया होगा आप लोगों का सबका
राइट यस इट्स लगिंग टुडे आई डोंट नो वई इट
इज लगिंग क्योंकि इंटरनेट स्पीड भी सही है
सब कुछ एवरीथिंग इज गुड आई डोंट नो कि वई
देर इ सम
इशू थोड़ा नेटवर्क इशू है आई
थिंक स्पीड इशू है मेरे ख्याल से स्पीड इ
लेस या देर इ सम स्पीड
इशू
हां देर इज सम स्पीड ू थोड़ा कम है
नेटवर्क स्पीड अभी जो मेरा प्लान है उससे
कम है इस वजह से शायद कुछ हो रहा होगा बट
स्टिल इट इट्स विबल
राइट अभी सही है हम बीच में रुक जा रही है
ना बार-बार रुक जा रही है राइट राइट राइट
राइट नहीं व्यू ज्यादा नहीं होता अभी
बताइए
अभी ओके देयर इज समथिंग
रंग अ
नाउ एवरीथिंग
गुड अभी सही है आप लोगों का अभी बिल्कुल
सही है
क्या एक बार बता
दीजिए ओके यहां पे इशू आ रहा है कुछ आई
डोंट नो व्हाट इज द इशू यहां मेरे फोन पे
आप अपने फोन प या लैपटॉप प जो भी है वहां
पर माउस का कर्सर ले जाकर लाइव पर क्लिक
कर दीजिए अपने डिस्प्ले व्यूअर में तब आ
रहा है
क्या कुछ लोगों के लिए सही चल रहा है
ओके ओके ठीक है कोई बात नहीं चलिए हम इसको
अभी फिलहाल अभी तो सही हो रही है शायद तो
अभी कंटिन्यू करते हैं अभी अभी शायद सही
हो रही है
राइट ठीक है तो यहां यह चीज क्लियर हो गई
इस तरीके से ओपन डायरेक्ट जो है आपका वो
काम करता है दिस वे ओपन डायरेक्ट वर्क्स
अब ओपन डायरेक्ट के ना पैरामीटर्स होते
होते हैं वो पैरामीटर्स पे आपको वो ओपन
इडायरेक्ट फाइंड करना है ठीक है अब जैसे
कि यूआरएल के अंदर पैरामीटर्स हो सकते हैं
राइट किसी भी टाइप के पैरामीटर्स हो सकते
हैं जैसे कि रीडायरेक्ट यू आरआईए
रीडायरेक्ट यूआरएल लिखा है रीडायरेक्ट
लिखा है व्यू लिखा है लॉग इन टू लिखा है
इमेज यूआरएल टाइप का पैरामीटर है रिटर्न
पैरामीटर है जैसे मैं आपको इसका एग्जांपल
बता देता हूं जस्ट गिविंग यू एन एग्जांपल
जैसे मैं एक वेबसाइट प चलता हूं ठीक है
टेस्ट ph.com ठीक है मैंने इस वेबसाइट पे
मैं इस वेबसाइट प गया नाउ आई एम ओपनिंग
दिस वेबसाइट ठीक है
अभी यह वेबसाइट ओपन हो गई अब मैं इसके
किसी एक पेज को ब्राउज कर रहा हूं जैसे
ब्राउज आर्टिस्ट पे जा रहा हूं ठीक है अब
यहां पे कमेंट ऑन दिस पिक्चर पे आ रहा हूं
और जैसे ही मैं इस पे आया तो यहां पे मुझे
एक यूआरएल मिली जहां पे एक पैरामीटर है ए
आईडी नाउ दिस ए आईडी पैरामीटर कैन बी
रिलेटेड टू ओपन रीडायरेक्ट एंड आप इस पे
कोई और पैरामीटर पास करके एंड मे बी आप
इसको ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो देख सकते हो कि
व्हाट इज देयर राइट कि क्या हो सकता है
जैसे अब मैं कैटेगरी पे चलता हूं मैं यहां
पे पोस्टर्स पे चलता हूं जैसे ही पोस्टर्स
प आ मैं यहां पे कैट इ इक्व ट 1 तो कैट इज
अ पैरामीटर अब मैं अगर यहां पे
https.com डाल देता हूं और मैं एंटर करता
हूं एंड इफ इट इज रीडायरेक्टिंग मी टू
google.com इट माइट बी अ ओपन रीडायरेक्ट
लेबिलिटी फिलहाल यह नहीं कर रहा बट अगर कर
देता है तो इट कैन बी कंसीडर्ड इट विल बी
अ ओपन डायरेक्ट लेबिलिटी अभी जैसे मैं इस
पे चलता हूं मैं यहां
पे प्रोफाइल पे चलते हैं यहां पे प्रोफाइल
पे अगर कुछ है तो यहां पे नथिंग इज़ हियर
मैं यहां पे करता हूं टेस्ट एंड यहां पे
मैं लॉगइन करता हूं टेस्ट से यहां लॉगइन
करते हैं लॉगइन करते हैं यूज़र इंफो आ रही
है यहां पे राइट यूज़र इंफो के बाद अपडेट
करते हैं यहां पे हमारा अपडेट होके आ
जाएगा और यहां पे सर्च क्वेरी आ रही है
राइट अब सर्च क्वेरी में मैं मान लो कि आई
एम पुटिंग एनीथिंग लाइक अ अ
ओपन रीडायरेक्ट ये मैंने सर्च कररी में
डाला जैसे ही मैंने सर्च कररी में डाला तो
यहां पे ऊपर में यूआरएल क्या है यूआरएल है
देन टेस्ट इज इक्वल ट क्वेरी तो हमारे पास
एक पैरामीटर आ चुका है नाउ इस पैरामीटर पे
हम टेस्ट आउट कर सकते हैं अपने क्वेरी तो
https.com यहां पे जो ओपन डायरेक्ट की
पेलोड है उसको डालेंगे एंड वी विल ट्राई
कि इफ इट इज रीडायरेक्टिंग टू
रीडायरेक्टिंग अस टू google.com अगर
रीडायरेक्ट कर देता है तो इट्स वल्नरेबल
अब इसको हम इसको हम एक एग्जांपल के तौर प
भी देख लेते हैं कैसे देख लेंगे वो भी हम
देखते हैं जैसे हमने ये टेस्ट ph.com खोला
इसको हमने ये चीज ऐसे कर दी ठीक है अब
देखो अब मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पे मैं बब
सूट ओपन कर लेता हूं राइट सो आई एम गोइंग
टू स्टार्ट बॉब
सूट चलिए तो बॉब सूट का जो हमारा वाला
वर्जन है कहां गया वो यह रहा तो लेट्स
स्टार्ट द बॉब
सूट
ओके
स्टार्टिंग हां अब हम यहां पर बब सूट को
स्टार्ट कर चुके
हैं प्रॉक्सी को डिसेबल कर देते हैं एंड
यहां पर हम ब प्रॉक्सी को इनेबल करके एंड
अब जो है इस वेबसाइट को हम लोड करते हैं
वापस से हम इसको टेस्ट पीएचपी डव वेब को
लोड करते हैं टारगेट पे चलते हैं एंड यहां
पे हमारा आ चुका होगा नाउ वी कैन व्हाट वी
कैन डू राइट क्लिक ऐड टू स्कोप हम स्कोप
में इसको ऐड करते हैं एंड देन हम इसको
फिल्टर कर देते हैं सो इन स्कोप आइटम्स
ओनली हमारे पास ये आ चुका है ना व्हाट वी
आर गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू स्पाइडर
दिस तो राइट क्लिक किया स्पाइडर सस होस्ट
नए वाले अगर बब सूट्स हैं आप वर्जन में है
2.1 में तो आपको वहां पे स्कैनिंग का
ऑप्शन मिल जाएगा यू कैन यूज द स्कैनिंग
ऑप्शन दैट इज आल्सो डूइंग द सेम थिंग राइट
ठीक है अब यहां पे हमारे पास रिजल्ट्स आ
रहे हैं स्पाइडरिंग हो रही है स्पाइडर पे
जाओगे तो आप देखोगे कि स्पाइडर इज रनिंग
एंड यहां पे रिजल्ट्स हमारे पास आए अब
रिजल्ट्स में हमारे पास पैरामीटर्स वाले
भी रिजल्ट आए अब देखो यहां पे बहुत सारे
पैरामीटर्स आपको मिल रहे हैं अब ये
पैरामीटर्स हमारे लिए बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है
नाउ दिस पैरामीटर आ वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट अब इन
पैरामीटर्स में हम इन पैरामीटर्स को
देखेंगे कि ये पैरामीटर्स एजिस्ट करते हैं
क्या कोई जैसे रीडायरेक्ट यू
डायरेक्ट यूआरएल हो गया रीडायरेक्ट हो गई
व्यू हो गया नेक्स्ट हो गया लिंक हो गया
यू हो गया गो हो गया ऐसे प ये तो एग्जांपल
पैरामीटर्स मैंने बताया हैं ऐसे बहुत सारे
पैरामीटर्स हो सकते हैं तो यहां पे हम
उसको टेस्ट आउट करेंगे कि कोई ऐसे
पैरामीटर अवेलेबल है अब उसको टेस्ट आउट
करने के लिए क्या करेंगे बब सूट में
जाएंगे सर्च पे क्लिक कर लेंगे सर्च पे जब
जाएंगे तो हमें क्या चाहिए ना हमें
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर में पैरामीटर चाहिए ये
वाले सार हमें रिस्पांस में ये पैरामीटर
अभी फिलहाल के लिए हमें रिस्पांस में ये
पैरामीटर नहीं चाहिए वी डोंट नीड द
रिस्पांस पैरामीटर तो हम रिस्पांस बॉडी
हेडर हटा देंगे रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी और हेडर
में रहने देंगे अब हमें पैरामीटर जो भी
चाहिए क्या चाहिए
भैया इन स्कोप ओनली वाले चाहिए ठीक है अब
यहां पे हमें चाहिए यूआरएल अब यूआरएल करके
सर्च करके गो पे क्लिक करेंगे तो आपको जो
पैरामीटर यूआरएल कंटेन करती है वो आपको
रिजल्ट्स में देखने को मिल जाएगी नाउ
हमारे पास यहां पे एक दोती च पाच रिजल्ट्स
मिले हैं जहां पे यूआरएल एक आपको पैरामीटर
मिलने देखने को मिला होगा ठीक है तो जैसे
हमारे पास यह गेस्ट पीएचपी वाली आ गई तो
इसमें देखते हैं कौन सा यहां पे कुछ
यूआरएल से रिलेटेड कुछ है क्या नहीं है यह
नॉर्मल सी हेडर में है तो इसमें कुछ नहीं
है हमारे काट में देखते हैं कुछ यूआरएल
टाइप नहीं इसमें भी कुछ नहीं है यहां
देखते हैं यूआरएल टाइप नो नथिंग सर्च
कमांड यहां पे कुछ यूआरएल टाइप मिलता है
क्या सो यूआरएल इनकोडेड ये दिस इज जस्ट अ
हेडर वो वाली है रिक्वेस्ट हेडर जो
है यूआरएल इंफो यहां पे भी कुछ ऐसा खास
नहीं है तो हम दूसरा कोई एक देखेंगे हम
देखेंगे अब कौन सा व्यू व्यू भी एक कीवर्ड
है तो व्यू पर जाते हैं व्यू इफ वी कैन
गेट व्यू नहीं व्यू नहीं है ओके देयर इज
सम अदर पैरामीटर्स आल्सो जैसे कि फाइल
पैरामीटर है रीडायरेक्ट है तो चलिए उनको
देख लेते हैं एक बार सो लेट्स फाइंड आउट
अबाउट द रीडायरेक्ट पैरामीटर रीडायरेक्ट
ले देखते हैं नहीं कुछ भी नहीं है रेड रेड
रेड रेड नहीं कुछ भी नहीं है यहां पर
देखते हैं फाइल
पैरामीटर यस सो देयर इज अ फाइल पैरामीटर
अब यहां पे एक फाइ फ पैरामीटर मिल गई ठीक
है और यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं कि यह गेट
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है फाइल पैरामीटर पे अब
हम इस पे क्या कर सकते हैं व्हाट वी कैन
डू वी कैन ट्राई आउट द ओपन रीडायरेक्शन वल
एबिलिटी कैसे कर सकते हैं राइट क्लिक किया
यहां पे हमने राइट क्लिक करके हमने यहां
पे इसको सिंपली इस पर्टिकुलर को आप कॉपी
कर सकते हो इस यूआरएल को या इस यूआरएल प
जाके आप अपने रीडायरेक्ट पैरामीटर जो है
वो डाल के चेक आउट कर सकते हैं कि हम ये
पॉसिबल है क्या तो हम राइट क्लिक करते हैं
सेंड टू रिपीटर करते हैं रिपीटर पे आ जाते
हैं यहां पे आप गो प क्लिक करेंगे तो आपको
यहां पे रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे 200 ओके करके
यहां पे कुछ रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे हैं राइट अब
नाउ यहां पे ना हम क्या करेंगे यहां पे
फाइल इज इक्वल टू के जगह पे हम यहां देखते
हैं
https.com यह रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है कि
नहीं कर रहा है लेट्स सी इफ इट इज़
रीडायरेक्टिंग ऑर नॉट 200 ओके यहां पे आ
रहा है यहां पे 200 ओके इट इज़ गोइंग एंड
अ राइट क्लिक करेंगे शो रिस्पांस इन
ब्राउज़र कॉपी करेंगे एंड यहां पे हम
ब्राउज़र में रिस्पांस देखेंगे इफ इट इज़
एक्चुअली डिडक्टिंग र नॉट तो यहां पे आ
रहा है कि यहां पे कंटेंस एंड एर bing.com
यहां पे ऐसा कुछ नहीं है सो इट्स नॉट
शोइंग एनीथिंग राइट सो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है हम दूसरे जो हमारे
पास
अ जो हमारे पास दूसरे पैरामीटर्स हैं हम
उन पे ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं वी कैन गो
एंड वी कैन ट्राई आउट ऑन देम तो यहां पे
वी आर गेटिंग अ लॉट ऑफ पैरामीटर्स राइट वी
आर गेटिंग लॉट ऑफ लॉट ऑफ पैरामीटर्स यहां
पे आप कोई से भी पैरामीटर उठा लीजिएगा
सर्च पैनल से भी आप उठा सर्च पैनल में हम
अभी जैसे फाइल क्या किया हमने अभी u इ टू
ऐसे सर्च कर सकते हैं अगर u इक्वल टू कुछ
मिलता है तो इफ लेट्स से u इ ट नॉट अ
यूआरएल नॉट अ यूआरएल राइट कुछ भी नहीं
यहां पे तो हमें कुछ नहीं मिला यहां पे हम
दूसरे यूआरएल पैरामीटर चेक आउट कर सकते
हैं लाइक कोई सा भी यूआरएल पैरामीटर वी
कैन चेक आउट जैसे कि अ पाथ चेक कर सकते
हैं वी कैन चेक टारगेट एक्सेट्रा
एक्सेट्रा राइट तो चलिए
हम पाथ पे चेक करते हैं इफ देयर इज समथिंग
पाथ नो
टारगेट
टारगेट नो एटीटीपी
अ यस वी आर गेटिंग सम एसटीटीपी ओके तो मैं
इक्वल्स टू एटीटीपी चेक कर लेता हूं
अ नो देर इज नो देर इज नो इक्वल ी ऐसा कुछ
नहीं एटीटीपी कॉलन
स्लश यहां देख लेते हैं यहां प कुछ
रिजल्ट्स हमें मिले हैं लाइक काइंड ऑफ दिस
रेफरर ये रेफरर है यहां पर रेफरल में आ
रही है यहां पर रेफरल में आ रही है यहां
पर रेफरल में आ रही है तो इस तरीके से
यहां पर हमने देखा एंड वी आर बेसिकली ट
व्हाट वी आर डूइंग एक्चुअली हम यहां पे
कोई भी एक रीडायरेक्ट पैरा ढूंढने की
कोशिश कर र है अगर कोई भी पैरामीटर मिल गई
उसपे हम अपने रिडक पेलो चिपका सकते हैं
एंड वी कैन लिटरली ट्राई आउट कि इफ इट इज
एक्चुअली वर्किंग और नॉट वर्किंग राइट तो
अगर हमारे पास जैसे फाइल इज इक्वल टू मिली
अब वैसे ही अगर हमारे पास कोई रीडायरेक्ट
करके रीडायरेक्शन वाली कोई चीज मिल जाती
कुछ ऐसा मिल जाता तो इट वुड बी ग्रेट ये
अच्छा होता तो हम इसको अभी हटा देते हैं
मान लो हम बहुत सारे और पैरामीटर्स हैं
यहां पे वी कैन ट्राई आउट मोर पैरामीटर्स
जैसे यहां पे हमारे पास आर्टिस्ट पैरामीटर
मिल रहा है राइट तो हम आर्टिस्ट पैरामीटर
सेंड टू रिपीटर पे क्लिक कर देंगे यहां पे
हमें एक काट ड पीए वाली पैरामीटर है तो हम
यहां पे भी सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देंगे हमें
यहां पे डेल का डेल इ इक्वल टू डिलीट वाली
है सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देंगे गेस्ट बुक में
हमारे पास क्या है नेम एंड ऑल है तो हम
इसको सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देंगे देन यहां पे
हमारे पास सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देंगे सारे
रिपीटर्स पे भेज देते हैं हमारे पास
प्रोडक्ट पिक इज इक्वल टू वन है सेंड टू
रिपीटर कर देंगे वी कैन सेंड टू
रिपीटर यूजर इंफो में भी हमारे पास
पैरामीटर्स कुछ है इसको भी हम कर सकते हैं
बट हम फिलहाल के लिए रिपीटर पे आ जाते हैं
रिपीटर में हमरे बहुत सारे आ चुके हैं तो
अब अभी यहां पे पहला ये जो था इसको हम
रिमूव कर देते हैं दूसरे आते हैं आर्टिस्ट
= 1 पे राइट नाउ व्हाट वी कैन डू गो पे
क्लिक करते हैं हमें रिजल्ट्स यहां पे
मिलेंगे ठीक है हमें रिजल्ट्स यहां पे
मिले ठीक है अब हम यहां पे एक हमारा
पैरामीटर डालेंगे यहां पे पैरामीटर क्या
डालेंगे आटस इ
एटीपीए कॉलन google.com इफ इट इज
रीडायरेक्टिंग इट्स गुड यहां पे गो पे
क्लिक करेंगे 200 हो क्या आ रहा है यहां
देखते हैं google.com कहीं पे दिख रहा है
क्या भैया google.com ओ google.com आ रहा
है बट इट्स नॉट रीडायरेक्टिंग एक्चुअली बट
या इट्स गिविंग अस google.com यहां पे वो
आउटपुट में आ रहा है बट इट्स नॉट
रीडायरेक्टिंग रीडायरेक्टिंग होता तो य
लोकेशन में आपको कहीं ना कहीं कहीं ना
कहीं आपको दिख जाता है कि रीडायरेक्ट हो
रही है बट इट्स नॉट रीडायरेक्टिंग राइट तो
हम एक बार शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर करके
इसको चेक आउट मैनुअली भी एक अपनी संतुष्टि
के लिए एक बार चेक आउट कर सकते हैं इफ वी
आर एक्चुअली गेटिंग डायरेक्टेड ठीक है तो
यहां पे हमने देख लिया अब हम इसको कॉपी कर
लेते हैं हमारे https.com
को अब देखो मैं इसका आपको टूल का
इंपॉर्टेंस
बताऊंगा यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं है चलिए ठीक
है कोई दिक्कत नहीं इसको ऐसे ही रहने देते
हैं इस पे चलते हैं डेल = 1 यहां पे हम
अपना चिपका देते हैं गो पे क्लिक कर देते
हैं लेट्स सी इफ इट इज गिविंग सम काइंड ऑफ
थिंग यहां पे google.com कर लेते
हैं देर इज नथिंग सो कुछ भी नहीं है यहां
पे लेट्स सी हियर नेम में यहां पे टेस्ट
जो है यहां पे हम google.com नेम में डाल
देते हैं गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं लेट्स
सी व्हाट इज एनिंग ओके सो इट्स गिविंग
google.com बट आई डोंट नो व्हाट इट विल
लुक लाइक सो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर एंड यहां
पे हम ब्राउजर में चलते हैं एंड एंटर करते
हैं एंड सिंपली google.com राइट ये सिंपली
google.com दे रहा है अब यहां पे ना हम एक
और चीज कर सकते हैं हम यहां पे हाइपरलिंक
इंजेक्शन भी चेक आउट कर सकते हैं वी कैन
चेक आउट द
html.com आया ना तो यहां पे ये रिफ्लेक्ट
हो रहा है google.com राइट सो हम यहां पे
डायरेक्ट के समय अब वो कैसे होगा तो सिंपल
सा एक हम कोड लिखेंगे एक कोड बना देंगे
क्या करेंगे यहां पर अभी फिर से गायब हो
गया क्या
ये
हा ठीक है सिंपल सा हम एक कोड बना देंगे
कोड क्या बनाएंगे यहां पर एच आर एफ थ
स्कूल्स ठीक है यह हमने सर्च
किया आ य पे यह रहाय य वाली आ गई यहां पर
सेम इस सेम हम पलट को यहां पर डालेंगे
अभी सही है विजिबिलिटी आप लोगों को अभी
सही है आप लोगों को विजिबिलिटी सही है अभी
तो फिर से रुक गई है मेरे यहां
पर अभी सही
है एवरीथिंग गुड
बता
दीजिए ठीक है चलिए तो अभी यहां पे हमने
एचआरएफ ले लिया है एचआरएफ हम क्या कर रहे
हैं यहां पे एचटीएमएल हाइपर लिक इंजेक्शन
कर रहे हैं तो हमने सिंपली यहां पे w3
स्कूल से एक एचआरएफ का कोड उठा लिया है
राइट तो वी हैव टेकन दिस कोड एंड हम इसको
भी यहां पे मैनुअली डाल के देख सकते हैं
राइट अगर कुछ यहां पे मिल रहा है हमें तो
तो हम यहां पे क्या कर देते हैं नेम में
अब क्या कर देते हैं v कर देते हैं इस
तरीके से एंड यहां पे हम
https.com डाल देते हैं google.com डाल
देते हैं राइट एंड यहां पे हम इसको गो पे
क्लिक कर देते हैं गो पे क्लिक करेंगे 200
ओके आ रहा है अब हम इसको राइट क्लिक करके
शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर कॉपी कर लेंगे
कॉपी करके यहां पे हम इसका रिस्पांस एक
बार देख लेते हैं क्या आ रहा है नाउ व्हेन
एवर वी आर सेंडिंग रिस्पांस यहां पे आ रहा
है तो यहां पे विजिट w3 school.com आ रहा
है बट यह google.com हमने डाला हुआ है
यहां पे अब हम जैसे इस पर क्लिक करेंगे इट
इज गोइंग टू google.com आप सबने देखा इट
इज रीडायरेक्टिंग टू google.com राइट अब
ये जो रीडायरेक्ट हुआ दिस दिस यू कैन नॉट
टेल ओपन रीडायरेक्शन ये ओपन रीडायरेक्शन
नहीं है बट दिस इज काइंड ऑफ़ एचटीएमएल
इंजेक्शन जो यहां पे आपने काम किया एक तरह
से आपका काम आया ठीक है तो अब यह भी एक
अप्रोच आप रख सकते हैं कि अगर आपको कुछ
मिल जाता है फिर आप उसको एस्केलेट करने की
कोशिश करें चेन अप करने की कोशिश करें एंड
आगे उसको और भी क्रिटिकल लेबिलिटी में
लेकर जाएं फिर ओपन रीडायरेक्शन की तरफ
एक्सएसएस की तरफ अकाउंट टेकओवर की तरफ
एसएसआर की तरफ आप लेकर जाए तो यह ज्यादा
बेनिफिशियल आपके लिए रहेगा अब यह तो
नॉर्मल सा हो गया चलिए अब यहां पे देखते
हैं यहां पे पीप = 12 नाउ लेट्स सी इफ इट
इज वर्किंग हियर आपका
https.com
गो पे क्लिक करते हैं यहां पे आ रहा है
यहां पे एटीटीपी पै अब यहां पे आ चुका
google.com हमने यहां पे किया ठीक है अब
राइट क्लिक
किया शो रिस्पांसस ब्राउजर कॉपी एंड यहां
पे गए एंड यहां पे अब हम सेम को एक्सेस कर
रहे हैं य यहां पे हमारे पास कुछ नहीं आ
रहा यहां पे बेसिकली चेक आ रहा है यहां पे
लिंक वन आ रहा है लिंक वन इज google.com
यहां पे क्लिक करते हैं एंड इट्स टेलिंग
वड google.com इट्स टेलिंग वड google.com
दैट्ची है तो आप इस तरीके से भी चेक आउट
कर सकते हैं जो भी आपके पास पैरामीटर्स
आते हैं यहां पे पिक वन है वैसे ही सेम
चीज है यहां पे पिक वपक्ड पप यहां यहां पे
भी सेम आप
एचटीटीपीएस google.com ऐसे अभी अभी मजा
आएगा अभी अभी तो देखते जाओ गो प क्लिक
करते हैं एंड यहां पे वी गेट द रिस्पांस
सो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर कॉपी एंड लेट्स
सी अगर डायरेक्ट हो जाता था तो ये हो जाता
पॉसिबल अगर डायरेक्ट होता तो हो जाता ठीक
है चलिए तो ये तो आपने एक अप्रोच देख लिया
कि हम इस तरीके से चीजों को कर सकते हैं
अब हम यहां पर चलते हैं एक हमारा दूसरा जो
अप्रोच है वो ट्राई करते हैं और उसपे एक
बार हंट करने की कोशिश करते हैं ठीक है अब
हम जो यूज़ करने वाले हैं दैट वी आर गोइंग
टू यूज़ अ टूल हम एक टूल यूज़ करने वाले
हैं एक टूल यूज़ करने वाले हैं जो काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है एंड उस टूल का नाम है
वेबक यूआरएल वेबैक यूआरएल यूज़ करने वाले
हैं तो हम क्या करेंगे बेसिकली वी आर
गोइंग टू यूज़ द फर्स्ट टूल वेबक यूआरएल
एंड उससे हम हंट करेंगे पहले तो वेबक
यूआरएल के लिए आपको सिंपली जाना होगा गिट
हब पे सो वे बैक यूआरएल यू कैन गेट द वे
बैक यूआरएल टूल फ्रॉम हियर एंड आप सिंपली
इसको इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं इस तरीके से गो
इंस्टॉल कमांड चला के गो से इंस्टॉल कर
सकते हैं हमारे पास यहां पे टर्मिनल
ऑलरेडी ओपन है एंड यहां पे वे बैक इज
ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल तो आपको इंस्टॉल करना है
गो कॉन्फिडो चाहिए आपके सिस्टम में गोलंग
इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए
दैट्ची से कुछ ओपन हो जाता है नाउ व्हाट
व्हाट अ वी हैव टू डू हमें यहां पे मैं
फुल स्क्रीन पे चला जाता हूं यहां पे
थोड़ा बड़ा कर देता हूं हमें यहां पे वेबक
यस पे जाके एंड नाउ वी हैव टू गिव द
टारगेट डोमेन तो टारगेट डोमेन हम यहां पे
देते हैं टेस्ट
पीएपी one web.com ठीक है ये हमने दिया अब
हम इस पे एंटर करते हैं नाउ व्हेन एवर वी
विल एंटर हमें जो भी यूआरएल है ना जो भी
यूआरएल हैं इससे रिलेटेड जो वेब एक से फैच
करके ये दे रहा है हमें वो मिल जाएंगे
राइट ये सारे यूआरएल आपको मिल रहे हैं बट
इन
यूआरएसएस में हमें बेसिकली क्या चाहिए
हमें चाहिए वैसे यूआरएल जो एक्चुअली कोई
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहे हो किसी तरह का
रीडायरेक्शन कर रहे हो वी नीड दोज काइंड
ऑफ यूआरएल तो उस टाइप के यूआरएल के लिए हम
ग्रेप कमांड का यूज़ कर सकते हैं वी कैन
यूज़ लिटरली ग्रेप कमांड तो हम क्या
करेंगे अभी यहां पे गोइंग डाउन हम यहां पे
क्लियर कर देते हैं सेम कमांड यहां चलाते
हैं अब यहां पे हम ग्रेप को पाइपलाइन
करेंगे एंड यहां पे हम ग्रेप के अंदर ना
क्या पुट करेंगे इज इक्वल टू
ऐसा मुझे चाहिए एचटीटीपी हो ऐसा मुझे
चाहिए अब मैं एंटर करूंगा ना तो जो
एचटीटीपी वाले आपके रिजल्ट्स होंगे उनको
यह फिल्टर करके दे देता है तो यह देखिए यह
सारे एचटीटीपी वाले जो रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा
है री डायर आरई डीआई आर जो है ना यह मिल
रहा है इसमें आरई डीआई आर जो हमने वहां पे
बब शूट में उस टाइम पे हमने नहीं देखा था
आरडीआई आर मे बी वी कुड हैव फाउंड आरई
डीआई आर अगर हम ऐसे जाते टारगेट में यहां
पे और यहां पे सर्च करते अगर आर ईडी आई आर
देन वी कुड हैव गॉट सम समथिंग तो यहां पर
हमें एक आरडीआई आर का यहां पर कुछ मिला य
पर राइट व गट र आरडीआई आर ठीक
है तो अब हम एक यूआरएल को यहां पर उठाएंगे
कोई सा भी एक यूआरएल हम चेक करने के लिए
तो जैसे मेरे पास एक यूआरएल यह वाली
यूआरएल है मैं इसको यहां पर यहां पर कॉपी
कर लेता हूं सिंपली र कॉपी यहां पर यहां
पर चलते हैं पेस्ट कर देते हैं और यहां पर
आप देख सकते
हैं लाइक वी कैन सी हियर
यू कैन सी हियर दिस इज द दिस इज द यूआरएल
यहां पे मैं इसको पूरा ऐसे कॉपी कर लेता
हूं
https.com ट्स इट कॉपी एंड नाउ लेट्स ओपन
इट राइट सो लेट्स पेस्ट इट एंड यहां पे r
= एचटीटीपीएस समथिंग है यहां पे हम क्या
करेंगे google.com डालेंगे और एंटर करेंगे
एंड इफ इट इज रीडायरेक्टिंग टूू
देयर इज अ रीडायरेक्शन लेबिलिटी ओपन
रीडायरेक्शन लेबिलिटी सो यू ल सॉ वी जस्ट
रीडायरेक्टेड टू ओपन टू google.com आपने
अभी देखा कि हमने इस पर्टिकुलर पाथ प हमें
रीडायरेक्शन मिली है तो हमारा पेलोड क्या
था हमारा क्या था
वो जो पैरामीटर था वो क्या था जो हमें
मिला था पैरामीटर पैरामीटर पैरामीटर क्या
था मुझे बताइए आप लोग जल्दी बताइए चैट में
बता दीजिए पैरामीटर क्या था यह जो
वल्नरेबल पैरामीटर है वो कौन सा वल्नरेबल
पैरामीटर है करेंटली इसके लिए ये बता दए
जल्दी फटाफट बताइए एवरी बडी प्लीज लेट मी
नो व्हाट वास द पैरामीटर हियर व्हाट इज द
पैरामीटर
हियर एब्सलूट करेक्ट पैरामीटर इज जस्ट आर
जस्ट आर हमारा पैरामीटर जो हमने यहां पर
भी मेंशन कहीं प किया होगा या नहीं नहीं
भी किया होगा य पैरामीटर हो सकता है आपका
आर पैरामीटर यू और आर और कुछ भी इस टाइप
के पैरामीटर्स हो सकते हैं सो वी गट द
पैरामीटर एंड वी आर
हियर रीडायरेक्टेड टू द google.com राइट
अब देखिए उसी तरी ये तो r पैरामीटर हो गई
और भी पैरामीटर्स है भैया और भी जैसे कि
अभी अभी देखो r इ इक्वल टू है ना यहां पे
और पैरामीटर से देख सकते हैं अगर कुछ मिल
जाता है कोई और पैरामीटर हो जाती है तो वी
कैन फाइंड आउट अदर पैरामीटर्स आल्सो तो
नीचे जाते हैं यहां पे कोई और पैरामीटर है
क्या नहीं अभी फिलहाल तो r पैरामीटर है
हमारे या सो वी हैव द आर मेनली r पैरामीटर
यहां पे जो कि वल्नरेबल है जो कि जहां पे
हमने रीडायरेक्ट कर लिया है तो हम इस
तरीके से क्या कर सकते हैं वी कैन गेट द
रिजल्ट वे बैक यूआरएल से हमें रिजल्ट्स
मिल जाएंगे एंड वी कैन गो अहेड विद द ऑल द
यूआरएल हम ये टारगेट किसी डोमेन के लिए कर
सकते हैं वी कैन यू कैन डू दिस काइंड ऑफ
थिंग्स ऑन अ टारगेट डोमेन अब टारगेट डोमेन
कहां से आएगा अभी मैं आपको बताता हूं जैसे
हमारे कोई डोमेन है जैसे मैं मान लो एलएस
करता हूं मेरे पास एक डोमेन की लिस्ट है
तो मैं सीडी करके इनडीड में चलता हूं यहां
पर मेरे पास टारगेट है कैट
ऑल
लाइव यहां पर मेरे पास एक ये डोमेन की
लिस्ट है ठीक है इं डोमेन की लिस्ट है मैं
अब इसको भी इसमें से भी कोई डोमेन ले सकता
हूं लाइक एनी डोमेन जो मुझे लगता है कि
वहां प हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं वी कैन
जस्ट गिव इट ट्राई आउट तो हम कोई सा भी
डोमेन ले सकते हैं जैसे कि अब इसमें से
कोई सा भी डोमेन ले लो जैसे कि मैं च चलो
रूस ind.com इसको ले लेते हैं मैंने
कंट्रोल करके क्लिक किया ताकि ये पता चले
कि एगजैक्टली ये डोमेन कहां पे क्या कर
रहा है तो आ रहा है पेज नॉट फाउंड ठीक है
तो इस परे चलो हटा देते हैं लेट्स गो टू
टेंप्लेट व्हाट इज दिस
एरर ड आम व्हाट इज दिस पेज नॉट
फाउंड चलिए हां पेज नॉट फाउंड पेज नॉट
फाउंड है ना तो ट्राई करना बनता है एक बार
राइट तो v एन कैनरी वाली जो चीज है v एन
कैनरी वाली इसमें भी आपको पेज नॉट फाउंड
करके आ रहा है राइट तो हम इसको भी एज अ
टारगेट डोमेन बिल्कुल ले सकते हैं सो नाउ
वी विल हैव टारगेट डोमेन vn.com
अब हम इसको फिर से वेबैक यूआरएल में पास
कर सकते हैं हमारा एज अ टारगेट डोमेन यहां
पर हम ग्रेप कर सकते हैं एंड ग्रेप करके
हम देख सकते हैं इफ देयर इज सम काइंड ऑफ
रीडायरेक्ट पैरामीटर्स अब देखो अब
रीडायरेक्ट पैरामीटर्स तो बहुत सारे हैं
राइट वी हैव अ लॉट ऑफ रीडायरेक्ट
पैरामीटर्स तो अब हम खुद का एक वन लाइनर
बनाएंगे बताओ बनाए वे बैक यूआरएल का यूज
करके वन लाइनर बनाए खुद का खुद का देखो
कोड कैसे तुम बिना जानकारी के लिख सकते हो
बताओ अगर बनाना है तो मैं बना के बताता
हूं कैसे बना सकते हैं खुद का एक छोटा सा
स्क्रिप्ट लिख लेंगे शहर जीपीटी है क्या
ही को टेंशन है राइट सो लेट्स डू राइट चल
करते हैं क्या बोलती है पब्लिक पब्लिक
बोलती है कि चाहिए
बताइए तो बताइए पब्लिक बोलती है चाहिए तो
बताइए चाहिए ठीक है अब देखो कैसे चार
जीपीटी का यूज़ किया जाता है वह भी तुमको
मैं सिखा रहा हूं तुमको मैं एआई भी सिखा
रहा हूं राइट वेबक का यू वेबक का सेटअप
कैसे करना है वेबक यूआरएल सेटअप बहुत इजी
है सिंपली यहां पे इसको कॉपी करो गोल
इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए अपने टर्मिनल में जाओ
और यहां पे पेस्ट करो वेबैक
यूआरएल जस्ट गो पेस्ट एंड यहां से ये वाला
ये वाला हटा देना एरो यार नहीं तो काम
नहीं करेगा ये वाली अब गो इसको करो एंटर
करो आपका इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा वे बैक
दैट्ची जीपीटी पे नाउ चा जीपीटी प जाएंगे
अब हम इसको बोलेंगे हमारे लिए टूल बनाने
के लिए लेकिन ये टूल बनाएगा ऐसे नहीं और
हमें ऐसे भी नहीं बोलना है एकदम सिंपल से
हमें देखो कैसे कर सो नाउ आई एम गोइंग टू
टेल चार्ज
बीटी एक्ट एस अ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल
विथ यर्स ऑफ एक्सपीरियंस यस ऑफ
एक्सपीरियंस
एंड एंड मास्टर
ऑफ
ओस टॉप 10 ठीक है ट्स इट आप मास्टर है
मैंने एंटर करके भेज दिया एब्सलूट लेट्स
ड्राइव इन टू इट तो ये बन गया आपका मास्टर
ओ टॉप 10 का एंड अब ये एक प्रोफेशनल भी है
जिसको काफी सारा एक्सपीरियंस है ठीक है अब
मैं यहां से पूछता हूं आई नीड सम हेल्प
रिगार्डिंग
ओपन री
डायरेक्शन वल्नरेबल
चलिए तो ओपन इक्स लेबिलिटी से कुछ हेल्प
चाहिए तो हमने इनसे बोला तो अब यह हमें
हमें जो है ओपन डायरेक्शन बताने लगे कि
ओपन डायरेक्शन कैसे होती है तो फिलहाल के
लिए हमें इसको यह चीज नहीं चाहिए तो हम
इसको अभी बंद कर देते हैं हमें ये चीज
नहीं चाहिए राइट हमें क्या चाहिए भैया
हमें चाहिए ओपन डायरेक्शन वलने बिलिटी के
बारे में इससे पूछना है इससे टूल इससे
स्क्रिप्ट बनवानी है राइट चलिए तो अब क्या
यहां पर करते हैं आई नीड
अ वन
लाइनर वन लाइनर
कमांड यूजिंग वन लाइनर कमांड च
से वे बैक यूआरएल
टूल यूरल
टूल ठीक
है टू फेच ऑल
द
ओपन ऑल द ओपन
रीडायरेक्ट टू फेच ऑल द
यूआरएल ऑल द यूआरएल एंड फिल्टर इट विथ
ग्रेप आपको ग्रेप से इसको फिल्टर करना है
ठीक है आई नीड वन लाइनर कमांड च यूस वेबक
यर टूल टू फेच ऑल द यूआरएल ऑफ अ टारगेट
एंड फिल्टर इट यूज विथ ग्रेप फॉर पॉसिबल
ओपन
रीडायरेक्ट
पैरामीटर्स इंक्लूड ऑल
पॉसिबल पैरामीटर्स ठीक है कर दिया हमने अब
यहां पे ये ओपन रीडायरेक्ट से रिलेटेड एक
हमारे टूल एक हमें एक कमांड बना के यहां
पे देगा तो चलिए यह कमांड यहां प हमें बना
के यहां प दे रहा है ठीक है अलग-अलग यहां
पे ओके अब यहां पे मुझे इको कमांड ये इको
कर रहा है e target.com फिर इसको दे रहा
है वेबैक यूआरएल में इतना कौन हमें
रीडायरेक्ट करेगा हम एक सिंपल वे बैक यस
चाहिए सो यहां पे हमें
चाहिए डू नॉट यूज
इको एंड आपको को इ को यूज नहीं करना
है ओनली यूज वे बैक यूआरएल
कमांड यूआरएल वे बैक
यूआरएल एंड
ऐड ऑल
पॉसिबल
पैरामीटर्स ठीक है यह हमने किया जो यहां
पर स्पैम कर रहे हैं उनको हमें हटाना
पड़ेगा म्यूट करना पड़ेगा
तो प्लीज डोंट स्पैम ठीक है इट्स
रिक्वेस्ट प्लीज
डोंट ओके
तो यहां पे हम आ चुके हैं अब यहां पे हमें
एक यूआरएल हमें एक मिल गया अब यहां पे
हमें जो रिजल्ट्स मिला है यह देखिए एक वन
लाइनर आपका तैयार हो चुका है वन लाइनर इज
टोटली रेडी गाइज रेडी गाइ रेडी टोटल रेडी
है यू कैन यूज द फॉलोइंग ऑनलाइन टू फेच ऑल
द यूआरएल यूजिंग वेब फिल्टर ऑल द पॉसिबल
ओपन इक्स पैरामीटर्स अब यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं कवर ऑल पॉसिबल ओपन पैरामीटर्स
नेम्स अब यहां पे हमारे पास रिजल्ट्स आ
चुके हैं हम इसको यहां पे कॉपी कर लेते
हैं इट्स गट इट गॉट कॉपीडब्ल्यूबी
मैं क्या करता हूं आई एम जस्ट गोइंग टू
चेंज द
टारगेट ठीक है मैंने यहां पे पेस्ट किया
यह य वाला मिल गया अब यहां पे टारगेट जो
है हमारा ये टारगेट हम कर देते हैं टे पए
p1 web.com t ph.com हमने ये टारगेट दे
दिया राइट हम इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं एंड
अब जो है हम अपने टर्मिनल में चलते हैं
टर्मिनल में चलने के बाद वी आर
सिंपली पेस्टिंग दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग तो
हमने पेस्ट किया एंड दैट्ची उसके बाद हम
वेट करेंगे फॉर द रिजल्ट्स एंड जैसे ही
हमने वेट किया वी आर गेटिंग हियर कि हमारे
पास यहां पे जितने भी पॉसिबल रीडायरेक्ट्स
के थे पैरामीटर्स के वो सारे यहां पे
हमारे पास आ चुके हैं रिजल्ट्स में एंड इट
इज एक्चुअली वर्किंग तो ये आपका एक्चुअली
वर्क कर रहा है द कमांड इज एक्चुअली
वर्किंग राइट तो हमारे पास रिजल्ट्स आ गए
अब इस पे टारगेट के जगह पे इस टारगेट की
जगह पे आप कुछ भी टारगेट रख सकते हैं कोई
सा भी टारगेट हम लेके चल सकते हैं जैसे
हमारे पास ये कोई टारगेट है तो टारगेट ले
लेते हैं
लेटस लेट्स सी इनडीड टारगेट इनडीड से कोई
टारगेट एक उठा लेते हैं राइट
सो मैं पेज डाउन करके जल्दी से नीचे चला
जाता हूं एंड लेट्स सी तो यहां पर सीडी
इनडीड प चलते हैं एंड कैट और लाइव ड प
चलते हैं यहां से कोई एक टारगेट हम
उठाएंगे तो मैं उठाऊंगा
यहां
से वीपीएन
हटाओ चलो इसको कॉपी करते हैं लेट्स सी इफ
इ इट इ ओपनिंग
समथिंग ओके ठीक है यहां देखते हैं साइट कै
री
चलिए यहां से इसको देख लेते एक बार कोई भी
एक वेबसाइट हमें चाहिए टारगेट की तरह
चाहिए नॉट
सिक्योर्ड सो
जो या एक्समन कॉ
इस पर देखते हैं इस पर ट्राई आउट करते हैं
लेट्स से लेट्स ट्राई दिस xm.com ठीक है
तो यह एक टारगेट
है आई थिंक इट्स ट्रांग टू ओपन
इट हमें एक वैसा मिला था
जो पेज नॉट फाउंड हम उस भी ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं वी कैन ट्राई आउट देर आल्सो ल
ind.com हमें मिला है ठीक है ठीक है कोई
नहीं है न एन
इ चलिए इसको एक बार ओपन कर लेता लेट्स ओपन
इट एल 404 नॉट फाउंड 404 नॉट फाउंड है य
पे अब देखो अब मुझे यहां पर मान
लो लेट्स सपोज आईम नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग कि
कौन सी यूआरएल जो है वो कौन सा यूआरएल
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है कौन सा यूआरएल
रीडायरेक्ट नहीं कर रहा है मुझे यह नहीं
पता है तो इसके लिए भी ना आप एक टूल यूज
कर सकते हैं वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल यू कैन
जस्ट पास दैट टूल ऑन दिस काइ ऑल दीज
टारगेट्स आप इस टारगेट पे पास कर सकते हो
एंड वो जो टूल है वो है आपका ओपन
रीडायरेक्ट एक्स दिस इज अ वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल मैं यहां पे आपको टूल बता
देता
हूं यहां पे ओपन रीडायरेक्ट टेक्स सर्च कर
लेंगे आप ओपन रीडायरेक्ट टेक्स सर्च
करेंगे आपको गिट हप पे मिल जाएगा दिस टूल
इ मेड बाय देवांश बाथम है उन्होंने यह टूल
बनाया है तो इस टूल को हम यूज करेंगे एंड
ऑल क्रेडिट गोस टू द क्रिएटर ऑफ दिस टूल
राइट तो यहां पे हम जब इस टूल को यूज
करेंगे तो यूज करने का क्या तरीका है
सिंपली गिट क्लोन कीजिए सीडी ओपन डायरेक्ट
कीजिए एंड सेटअप ड एस को चला दीजिए ट्स इट
तो यहां पर ऑलरेडी कंफीग्रीएडएचटीएमएल
यहां पे एलएस करूंगा मैं तो ऑलरेडी जो ये
टूल है ओपन डायरेक्ट एक्स ये ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल्ड है एंड अभी जब मैं ओपन डायरेक्ट
एक्स सर्च
करूंगा जब मैं टाइप करूंगा इट विल जस्ट
ओपन इट हान एच देंगे यहां पे तो इसकी
हेल्प फाइल जो है ओपन हो जाएगी कुछ इस
तरीके से ये करता क्या है ओपन डायरेक्ट
टेक्स्ट टूल मैं आपको बता देता हूं सो
व्हाट इट डज बेसिकली देखिए दिस इ
स्क्रिप्ट द स्क्रिप्ट एग्जीक्यूटेड फ्रॉम
द कमांड लाइन ये ऑप्शंस है यहां पे ठीक है
ना देखिए यू कैन यूज दिस स्क्रिप्ट टू चेक
फॉर ओपन रीडायरेक्ट्स इन वेब एप्लीकेशन
हाउ एवर यू शुड ओनली यूज़ इट ऑन सिस्टम
दैट यू हैव बीन गिवन एक्सप्लिसिट परमिशन
ठीक है ओपन रीडायरेक्ट्स के लिए आप चेकआउट
कर सकते हैं इस पर्टिकुलर टूल से अब
चेकआउट कैसे करेंगे मैं आपको बताता हूं
इसको यूज़ करने का तरीका क्या है आप
सिंपली पाइपलाइन कर सकते हो किसी भी लिस्ट
ऑफ टारगेट यूल्स पे आप पाइपलाइन कर दीजिए
पेलोड अगर आपको असाइन करना है कोई पेलोड
चाहिए अगर आपको मेंशन करना है तो आप हान प
से पेलोड डाल सकते हैं और उसके बाद एक
कीवर्ड फर्स्ट डाल सकते हैं और कंक्रेंस
लिस्ट अ अ जो है वह आप सेट कर सकते हैं जो
कि डिफॉल्ट यहां पे 100 है तो आप उसको सेट
कर सकते हैं अगर आप नहीं देना चाहे तो आप
डायरेक्ट ओपन इडायरेक्ट टेक्स्ट को भी पास
कर सकते हैं अब जैसे कि मैं क्या कर देता
हूं मैं यहां डायरेक्ट इसको पास करता हूं
कैसे करूंगा मैं कैट और जो मेरी लिस्ट ऑफ
टारगेट यूआरएल है जिस पे मुझे देखना है कि
कोई लाइक कोई ओपन डायरेक्ट है कि नहीं है
तो मैं कैट करूंगा यहां पे इनडीड इनडीड के
अंदर में मेरा ऑल लाइव करके एक टच था
इसमें बहुत सारे सब डोमेंस हैं इनडीड के
मैं उसको यहां पे ले लूंगा राइट बहुत सारे
सब डोमस राइट तो मैं उसको यहां पे ले लेता
हूं एंड यहां पे मैं ओपन रीडायरेक्ट एक्स
जो है वह पास कर देता हूं ओपन रीडायरेक्ट
एक्स पास कर देता
हूं ठीक है दैट्ची
अगली बार कब ऑनलाइन आगे आज तो देख लो भाई
अगली बार का अगली बार देख लेना चलिए ठीक
है अभी आप देख रहे यहां पे रिजल्ट वी आर
गेटिंग आ फेचिंग द रिजल्ट तो अब यहां पर
रिजल्ट्स में हमें बहुत सार अभी तो यह 25
पर 26 पर कुछ हुआ है तो हम इसको कंप्लीट
होने देते हैं एंड अभी देख सकते हैं लगभग
20050 यूआरएल पर सेकंड यह कर रहा है
प्रोसेस
और लाइव को लाइव स्ट्रीम जब भी हो जो जब
भी आप करते हो तो उसको शेयर कर दिया करो
ग्रुप्स में टे ग्राम पे र जगह शेयर कर
दिया करो जहां भी तुम कर सकते हो इट विल
रियली हेल्प अस एंड लोगों तक पहुंचेगी
चीजें कि हां भाई एक फ्री क्लासेस हो रही
है और अगर आपको इसकी क्वालिटी पे डाउट है
तो आप लिंकन प जाइए लिंकन पर जाकर आप
देखिएगा कितने लोगों को बाउंट मिल रही है
हॉल ऑफ फेम स्वैग मिल रहा है एवरीथिंग
राइट
चलिए
अभी हां लगिंग का इशू तो है आज पता नहीं
क्या इशू है आई डोंट अंडरस्टैंड वई इट इज
हैपनिंग दे माइट बी सम इशू इंटरनेट इशू
होगा बट आप लोग यहीं पर कंटिन्यू रहिए
रुद्र सर वी हैव गॉट हल ऑफ फेम एंड वी हैव
टैग यू न लिंकन एज वी फाउंड बग ऑन टाटा
मोटर्स आरो एंड रुद्र वाओ क्या बात है
रुद्र मेनी मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशन रुद्र एंड
आरो फॉर गेटिंग द हॉल ऑफ हिम एंड एट टाटा
मोटर्स रियली रियली मींस अ लॉट आप लोग
जैसे काम करते हो ए आप लोग में से देखो
बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट्स बहुत सारी चीजें
करते हैं उनको बहुत सारी अचीवमेंट मिलती
है बट बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट जो हमें
एक्चुअली में आके एंड हमारे बारे में
बताते हैं लोगों को लिंकन वगैरह प तो हमें
काफी अच्छा भी लगता है एंड हमें लगता है
कि हां हम जो कर रहे हैं मेहनत उसको
अप्रिशिएट किया जा रहा है तो इ इट गिव्स
अस मोटिवेशन इनकरेजमेंट आती है एक तरह से
तो थैंक यू फॉर दैट कीप डूइंग दैट एंड वी
लिटरली आर प्राउड ऑफ दिस काइंड ऑफ पीपल
ठीक है जो एक्नॉलेज करते हैं हमारी
टीचिंग्स को
चलिए मी गट 50 यूरो प्लस स्वक्स क्या बात
है डेमन साइबर सेक कांग्रेचुलेशन टू यू टू
अ 50 य के लिए 50 य मिला है इनको अ प्लस
स्वैग मिला है सो इट्स ग्रेट बहुत बड़ी
बात है अच्छी बात है बहुत अच्छा बहुत
अच्छा तो हमारे को ओपन डायरेक्ट x ने क्या
किया बेसिकली लिस्ट ऑफ यूआरएल जो कहीं ना
कहीं रीडायरेक्ट हो रहे हैं वो हमें यहां
पे निकाल के दे दिया अब हम इस पे क्या कर
सकते हैं व्हाट वी कैन टेक सम काइंड ऑफ
एक्शन ऑन दिस काइंड ऑफ यू आरएस हमें अब
यहां पे एक्शन लेना है हम यहां पे आप
एक्शन ले सकते हैं हम सेम काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स
जो है ना हम वी कैन डू आल्सो ऑन वेबक
यूआरएल वहां पर भी हम ग्रेप कमांड का यूज
करके एंड वी कैन जस्ट डू इट ऑन अ सिंगल
टारगेट कि हां कुछ मिल रहा है क्या तो अभी
देखो य
पे इट इज अबाउट टू
ओवर यो इट्स मी नो सखिया ओनली अच्छा अच्छा
ठीक है ओके न
सखिया ग्रेट कंग ब्रदर सर यर 000 क्या बात
है यार कांग्रेचुलेशन अंकित आई हैव फाउंड
अकाउंट टेकओवर वटी इन इंडियन क्लाउड
सर्विस प्रोवाइडर कांग्रेचुलेशन अंकित
कांग्रेचुलेशन
ओ थ मिस कॉन्फिन पवी क्लास ठीक है हां
आएगी आएगी
आई एम अ बिगनर एंड एंड टू स्मॉल टू गेट
बाउंटीज अ बिग थिंग दैट इज नॉट अ स्मल
थिंग ठीक है तो यहां पे देख सकते हैं बहुत
सारे रीडायरेक्टेड यूआरएल आपको यहां पे
इसने फेच करके दे दिया राइट इट हैज फेच्ड
अ लॉट ऑफ यूआरएल जो कहीं ना कहीं
रीडायरेक्ट हो रही है नाउ दिस इज़ वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट जैसे आप देखो यहां पे
ek.din ind.com एंड यह जा रही है
ek.din पे इस पे यह डायरेक्ट होके जा रही
है इस तरीके से रीडायरेक्ट हो रही है तो
आपको यहां पे देखना है कि कोई कोई
पैरामीटर तो ना मिल जाए कोई ऐसा कोई
पैरामीटर तो नहीं है जो हमें मिल जाए कुछ
ऐसा तो ना मिल जाए यह आपको ट्राई आउट करना
है देखना है तो जैसे यह देखो यहां पर टाइम
कीपिंग डट यहां पर एक थ लॉगिन ये एक
पैरामीटर पर मिल रहा है जा रहा है ये ठीक
है लेट्स फाइंड आउट इफ देर सम काइंड ऑफ
पैरामीटर्स
अवेलेबल
हा हा आप ऐसे भी कर सकते हो चेक आउट आप
ऐसे भी कर सकते हो जैसे आपने इसको कॉपी
किया आपने इस यरल को कॉपी कर लिया राइट
आपने इसको कॉपी किया नाउ लेट्स गो टू द
ब्राउजर लेट्स गो हियर एंड यहां पे आप
स्लैश करके पहले एंड यहां पे स्लैश करके
पहले ना यहां पे देख लो
एचटीटीपीएस google.com ऐसे आप करके देखिए
अगर यह काम कर रहा है क्या मैंने स्लश
करके google.com किया यहां पे इट्स नॉट
वर्किंग ओबवियस सी बात है यहां पे ये यहां
पे लेकर हमें आ गया अब यहां पे
हम
https.com हम डबल स्लश करके भी करेंगे तो
हम उसम भी ट्राई आउट करेंगे इफ इट इज
वर्किंग इन दिस वे नहीं इट्स नॉट
लेकिन हम इसको बब सूट के थ्रू भी आप कर
सकते हैं बब सूट के थ्रू भी हम देखेंगे अब
करके जैसे यह पर्टिकुलर पेज है राइट दिस
पर्टिकुलर पेज इ देयर नाउ वी कैन ट्राई
आउट डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ अदर पेलोड्स तो हम
क्या करते हैं व्ट वी आर गोइंग टू
डू यहां पर ऑलमोस्ट हो चुका
है ठीक
है सो यह हमारा यूआरएल है लेट्स गो टू द
बॉब सूट लेट्स ओपन इट चलिए इसको ओपन करते
हैं ऑ डॉट लॉगइन
को प्रॉक्सी प चलते हैं यहां
पे ठीक है यह इधर डायरेक्ट हो रहा है तो
मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं मैं यहां पे
प्रॉक्सी पे चलता हूं ठीक है यहां पे चलते
हैं नाउ यहां पे ना हमें पेलोड्स को यूज
करना है वी हैव टू यूज द पेलोड्स अब
पेलोड्स को कैसे यूज करेंगे रीडायरेक्शन
फाइंड करने के लिए वो भी मैं आपको बता
देता हूं कि वी कैन फाइंड थ्रू पेलोड्स तो
अभी क्या करेंगे ना
हम पेट्स की लिस्ट निकालेंगे रीडायरेक्ट
ओपन रीडायरेक्ट की तो ओपन डायरेक्ट की
पेट्स की लिस्ट आपको मिल जाएगी ओपन
रीडायरेक्ट पलट सर्च कर लीजिएगा
[संगीत]
तो इसको
हम या सो वी कैन गेट दिस पेलोड तो मैं
यहां पे कॉपी कर लेता हूं यहां पे एंड एक
बार
ना लेट्स मेक इट यहां पर मैं पेट की लिस्ट
बना लेता हूं मैंने इन पेट्स को यहां प
डाल दिया एंड दूसरी वाली जो पेलोड है उसको
भी कॉपी कर लेते हैं ठीक है यहां पर ये
पेलोड इसको हमने यहां पे कॉपी
किया
एंड जस्ट गोइंग टू एंटर इनटू दिस
पर्टिकुलर
पेलोड लिस्ट तो यहां पर पेलोड की लिस्ट बन
गई हमारे पास अब हम यहां पर इसको कंट्रोल
एस करके सेव कर देते हैं सेव कर देते हैं
ओ आर ओपन रीडायरेक्ट पेलोड्स के नाम से
राइट ओ आर पेलोड्स क्योंकि एक टेक्स्ट
फाइल है तो हम टेक्स्ट फाइल रहने देते हैं
एंड यहां पर हम इसको डेस्कटॉप प सेव कर
देते हैं ठीक है तो हमारे पास एक पेट की
लिस्ट आ गई अब हम कैसे कर सकते कैसे इसको
यूज करेंगे देखिए हम यहां प हमारा टारगेट
डोमेन है टाइप कीपिंग ind.com लॉगइन ठीक
है ट्स इट ग्रेट अब यहां पर हम जो है एक
टेस्ट पैरामीटर स्लैश देके हम पैरामीटर
चाहिए हमको जिसपे की पेट्स को हम यूज
करेंगे राइट सो वी आर गोइंग टू गिव दैट
पर्टिकुलर पैरामीटर हियर तो हम यहां
पे स्लैश करके यहां पे हम कर देते हैं
टेस्ट पैरामीटर और इसको हम कैप्चर करेंगे
बब सूट के अंदर में तो इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ करते
हैं ऑन करते हैं सॉरी एंड इसको हम कैप्चर
कर लेते हैं सो वी कैप्चरड हियर लॉगइन स्ल
लॉगइन स्ल टेस्ट इसको राइट क्लिक करके
सेंड टू इंट्रूडर कर देते हैं पैरामीटर को
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते हैं इंट्रूडर पे
जाते हैं पोजीशंस पे जाते हैं यहां सारा
कुछ क्लियर कर देते हैं और यहां जो टेस्ट
वाली पैरामीटर थी हमारी इसके जगह पर हम
पेलोड डाल सकते हैं वी कैन एंटर द पेलोड्स
एक्चुअली वी कैन एंटर द पेट्स तो हमारे
पास पेट्स यह रही र पेड ये रही आपको यह
दिख रही है
आपको दिस आर ऑल द पेलोड्स राइट यह सारे
हमारे पेलोड्स है इनको हम यूज करने वाले
चलिए तो
नाउ यहां पे चलते है अब यहां पे हम टेस्ट
के जगह पे यहां पे ऐड कर देते हैं एंड
यहां पे पे लोट्स पे चलते हैं पे लोट्स पे
चलके यहां पे सिंपल लिस्ट करते हैं लोड
करते हैं हमारी पेलोड वाली लिस्ट जो है
उसको लोड कर लेते हैं तो हम डेस्कटॉप पे
हैं वो
सो डेस्कटॉप पे चलते हैं हियर वी विल गेट
द पेलोड पेलोड पेलोड
पेलोड ओ आर पेलोड्स ओपन कर लेते हैं सारे
पेलोड्स यहां पे लोड हो जाते हैं आपके नाउ
हम ट स्टार्ट कर देंगे तो यहां पर देख
लेते हैं ऑप्शंस में चलके रीडायरेक्ट का
कुछ दिक्कत तो नहीं
है फॉलो डायरेक्शन
दे ठीक है तो रीडायरेक्शन फॉलो करने के
लिए यहां पर आ रहा है तो ठीक है अभी
फिलहाल के लिए रीडायरेक्शन कर लेंगे बट य
हम पेट को करते स्टार्ट अटक पर क्लिक कर
देते ठीक
है नाउ
इट्स स्टार्टिंग द
अटैक राइट ए यहां पर आपको पेट मिल रहे है
य जीरो पे 43 फोर लेंथ की यहां पे पेलोड
आपको मिल रही है उसके बाद हमें 411 आ रही
है 434 आ रही है कुछ डिफरेंट अगर लेंथ
मिलेगा तो हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं हां
हम यहां पे ना एक्सएसएस के थ्रू भी ओपन
डायरेक्शन ट्राई आउट मार सकते हैं जैसे अब
ये रहा ना ये ये आपको दिख रहा होगा राइट
तो यहां पे जावा स्किप कोड को डाल के यहां
पे एंड यहां पे कोशिश की गई है रीडायरेक्ट
करने की डायरेक्ट रीडायरेक्शन लेने की
हालांकि ये 403 स्टार्टस है तो वी डोंट
नीड दिस वी नीड 3 प एक स्टेटस आपको पता है
ना रीडायरेक्ट कौन सा होता है आपको पता है
ना रीडायरेक्ट स्टेटस कोड एसटीटीपी के कौन
से स्टेटस कोडस रीडायरेक्ट के लिए यूज किए
जाते हैं बता दीजिए मुझे जल्दी से चैट में
बता दीजिए एसटीडीपी के कौन से स्टेटस
कोड्स रीडायरेक्ट के लिए यूज में किया
जाते है किसी भी तरह का परमानेंट टेंपररी
कुछ भी जल्दी
बताइए बिल्कुल सही सो इट्स 3 प एक्स एक्स
राइट 30 302 यह सारे जो है डायरेक्ट लिए
किया जाता है ठीक है अब जैसे यहां
पे ये 403 है इट डजन वर्क 44 है 411 है
सेम सेम है यहां पे कुछ डिफरेंट तो मुझे
मिल नहीं रहा जो 302 या ऐसे प जाए य 403
है थ सो इट्स आई थिंक देख सकते हैं अगर
कुछ मिल जाए
तो तो मैं यहां पे ना स्टेटस कोड्स प
फिल्टर कर लेता हूं 403 नहीं चाहिए 302
वाले चाहिए लेंथ में जो है
थोड़ा सा हम लेंथ डिफरेंट करते हैं जैसे
मान लो यह लेंथ है 316 तो यह वाली जो
हमारे पास आई है राइट तो हम इस पर राइट
क्लिक करके कॉपी सो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर
कॉपी कर लेंगे एंड वल सी इफ इट इज
एक्चुअली वर्किंग और नॉट तो हम यहां प देख
सकते हैं कि यह पेलोड काम कर रहा है कि
नहीं तो अरे यार ये बॉब शूट किया ना हा तो
र देखेंगे करके इफ इट इज वर्किंग 400 बैड
रिक्वेस्ट 400 बैड रिक्वेस्ट सो इटस नॉट
एक्चुअली इटस नॉट वर्किंग
राइट तो यहां पर पेटस को यूज कर सकते हैं
अगर कुछ डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ लेंथ का पेलोड
हमें मिल जाता है तो
दैट्ची है तो ये पेलोड की तरह पेलोड का
यूज भी आप कर सकते पलट के थ्रू भी इस
तरीके से आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं अब हम
यहां पे ना बेसिकली एक टारगेट लेते हैं
लेट्स गो एंड गेट अ टारगेट एंड लेट्स हंट
ऑन दैट राइट हंट करते हैं वहां पे हम
अलग-अलग तरीकों का यूज करेंगे एंड वी विल
ट्राई सो अब मुझे टारगेट के लिए ना आप
किसी भी तरह के टारगेट के लिए जा सकते हैं
वी कैन गो फॉर एनी काइंड ऑफ टारगेट बट हम
यहां पे टारगेट लेंगे मैनुअल टारगेट्स जो
लेंगे वो लेंगे तो हम यहां पे एक बार कर
लेते हैं
फॉर बग
बाउंट टारगेट्स
राइट अब य प बग बाउटी डॉक्स में चलते हैं
कोई सा भी बग बांटी डॉक उठा लेते हैं एंड
इनमें से कोई सा भी ले लेते
हैं
डक्स
ओके दिस इ डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ थिंग
ओपन डायरेक्टस के कुछ इस तरीके ग डॉक्स भी
होते हैं तो आप इस तरीके से यूज भी कर
सकते हैं
google2 आर में देखते हैं कोई रिजल्ट है
क्या पास्ट आर में थ्रेट एबल फीड करके
हमारे रिजल्ट मिला है सो देखते हैं क्या
है
ये इफ दे आर काइंड ऑफ समथिंग को कुछ इनका
अगर बग बांटी प्रोग्राम है तो आई डोंट
थिंक
सो या नथिंग नथिंग लाइक
दैट सो यहां पास्ट आर से करके पास्ट 24
आवर्स करते हैं और भी रिजल्ट्स हमारे पास
आ जाएंगे रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर किसी का
चल रहा है तो ये रहा पैच टैक करके इनका है
चलिए अच्छी बात है डाक रीडिंग करके इनका
है अच्छी बात है प्लेनेट मोजिला है थ्रेड
एवल तो है ही यहां पे चलिए तो यहां पे हम
देख सकते हैं फरवरी 2025 में वैलिड
रिपोर्ट 456 मिले इनको इनका तो काफी अच्छा
खासा
मतलब काफी अच्छा खासा चल रहा है यह इनका
तो काफी ज्यादा लोग इसपे एक्टिव है तो वी
कैन नॉट चूज दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग इस टारगेट
को हम नहीं लेंगे यह बहुत अच्छी सोच होती
है जब बहुत ज्यादा भीड़ हो तो वहां से
पहले कट लो पहले कट लो अगर आप आप एक बिगनर
हो तो ठीक है अगर एडवांस यूजर हो फिर तो
जा ही सकते हो पास्ट वीक से ले लेते हैं
कोई सा भी एक टारगेट ले लेते हैं नीचे की
तरफ चलते हैं कोई थर्ड रो प चलते हैं एंड
इफर गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ टारगेट यर एट थर्ड
पेज सेकंड पेज पर चलते
हैं देर इ सम
टारगेट न नप नप
न ठीक है
ठीक है जेसी पेनी करके कुछ है यहां इस पे
चलते हैं रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर
प्रोग्राम है यहां पे तो इनमें इन्होंने
दिया हुआ है कि इस पे हम मेल कर सकते हैं
जेसी पेनी जो भी है यहां पे तो ये हमारा
टारगेट है हमारा अभी फिलहाल के लिए हम
इसको टारगेट चलते हैं चलो ये हमारा टारगेट
है राइट दिस इज द मेन टारगेट हमारा ये
टारगेट है जब भी कोई ओपन डक्ट की टारगेट
को तुम करो ना तो पूरी वेबसाइट की
फंक्शनैलिटी को समझने की कोशिश करो
फंक्शनैलिटी को चेक कर लो फंक्शनैलिटी को
यूज करो एंड देन ट्राई आउट करो आपका
डेफिनेटली जो है वो हो जाएगा डेफिनेटली जो
है व आपका काम कर जाएगा कई बार राइट सो
नाउ अब यहां पर देखिए अब यहां प इस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट प आ चुके हैं अब हम इस
टारगेट को एक्सप्लोर करेंगे पहले एंड
लेट्स फाइंड आउट इफ देर इज समथिंग ठीक है
तो व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू हम इस टारगेट
को बॉब सूट में जाएंगे टारगेट प जाएंगे
एंड यहां इन स्कोप आइटम्स जो है स्कोप से
इसको हटा देंगे रिमूव फ्रॉम स्कोप एंड नाउ
वल लो पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट हमने रीलोड किया
जसी पड कॉ करके जो भी
है यहां
पर हटाइए इसको यहां पर जाते टारगेट प नेबल
कर देते हैं यहां
पर लेट्स रीलोड ट
राइट ओके सो वी गट रीलोडेड यर नहीं चाहिए
भाई इसको परमिशन नहीं देनी है क्यों ऐसे
कर रहे हो
चलिए यहां पर रिजल्ट हमें आ गए जेसी पेनी
हमें खोजना है कहां है हमारे जेसी पेनी
भैया ए व हैव टू टारगेट सेट द टारगेट राइट
हमें यह टारगेट सेट करना है जैसी पेनी वेर
इ जसी जैसी जसी वेर इ र इ यू एपीआई जेसी
पेनी नहीं चलो यह भी एक देखो आप सब डोमेन
को भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो यू कैनन ट्रा
आट सब डोमेन तो हम य प जैसे यह कंटेंट
एपीआई जपनी क है ना दिस इ सब डोमेन तो आप
डोमन प भी ट्राट मार सकते हो ऐसा नहीं
सबोन ट्राट नहीं मार सकते हो तो इसको मान
लो कॉपी कर लो इसको अगर तुम्हे ऐसा कोई सब
डोमेन मिल रहा अच्छा सब डोमेन मिल रहा है
कॉपी
इट जस्ट कॉपी द यूआरएल
सो हमने सब डोमेन को य कॉपी मार ले ठीक
है अब यहां प मेन डोमेन प आ जाते हैं जेसी
पेनी जो हमारे भैया है जेसी पेनी कहां गए
जेसी पेनी र जेसी पेनी
आर गया कहां जसी पेनी
भाई वेयर इज द जेसी पेनी ऊपर आंगे हमारे
ऊपर
ऊपर कुछ दिख रहा है किसी को जेसी पेनी
कहां है भैया एवन कैन सी द टारगेट जेसी
पेनीड कॉम
हां आप क्राउड है तो क्राउड को पसंद है तो
क्राउड में जाओ कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यह रहा
जसी पेनी कहां गया
यार चलो एक काम करते हैं
ना नहीं मिल रहा ना
तो एक काम कर लेता है
ना तरीका आजमा लेते हैं ना इसको रीलोड कर
लेते हैं ट्स इट अभी तो आ जाएगा अपना
राइट सो नाउ वी शुड बी गेटिंग द जेसी
पेनीड कॉ हेयर इट इज द जेसी पेनी जेसी
पेनी जेसी बनी राइट तो हम यहां मिल चुका
है इसको ऐड टू स्कोप कर देते हैं एंड यस
वी आर स्कोप यहां पर हम ओनली स्को आइटम्स
कर देते हैं एंड ट्स इट तो अब हमारे पास
टारगेट आ चुका है अब हम इसको कंप्लीट
स्पाइडर कर देते स्पाइडर दिस होस्ट सो
इट्स स्टार्टिंग द स्पाइडरिंग यहां पर आप
देख सकते हैं स्पाइडरिंग हमारी स्टार्ट हो
चुकी है एंड स्पाइडरिंग जो है चलना श हो
चुका है एंड वी आर गेटिंग द रिजल्ट्स हियर
सो यहां पे हमें रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे हैं आप
देख सकते हैं पैरामीटर्स भर भर के
पैरामीटर्स मिले हैं क्या बात है यार वी
आर गेटिंग अ लॉट अ लॉट ऑफ पैरामीटर्स बट
इन पैरामीटर्स का हमें जरूरत तब पड़ेगा जब
हमें इसमें से फिल्टर आउट करना है हमें
फिल्टर के लिए ये पैरामीटर को यूज करना है
ठीक है तो अभी
देखिए अभी देखते हैं लेट्स
सी अब यहां पे ये पैरामीटर चलो ये आ गया
अब इसमें ना हम बस यही चीज नहीं करेंगे कि
बस ये अब इसमें आपको अकाउंट भी बनाना है
लेट्स सपोज साइन करना है आपको साइन इन प
भी जाना है लॉग इन भी करना है साइन अप भी
करना है सब करना है एवरीथिंग वी हैव टू डू
तो फिलहाल के लिए यहां पे स्पाइडरिंग अभी
भी चल रही है या अभी भी चल रही है
स्पाइडरिंग हो रही है उसके साथ-साथ ना आप
अलग-अलग जो हमारे पास पेलोड्स थे जो हमारे
पास ये पेलोड्स है ओपन डायरेक्ट ओपन
डायरेक्शन के इसको हम चेक आउट भी कर सकते
हैं साथ ही साथ चेक आउट कर सकते हैं कैसे
करेंगे सर्च प जाएंगे बब सूट सर्च पे
लेट्स सी रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस मिनी चाहिए
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर रिस्प रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी में
और इन स्कोप ओनली चाहिए एंड ए यहां पर हम
सर्च करेंगे आर ईडी आई आर रीडायरेक्ट कुछ
है क्या ना आर इ इक्वल टू कुछ है
क्या वी गट सम आर इ इक्वल टू लेट्स से इफ
देयर इज सम काइंड
ऑफ
यूजर
क्लस्टर आर ठीक है हमारे काम का तो आर कुछ
नहीं है ठीक है अभी फिलहाल के लिए इसको
छोड़ते हैं डायर इज इक्वल टू नहीं कुछ भी
नहीं है यूआरएल
देखते हैं यूआरएल इफ य आर गेटिंग सम काइंड
ऑफ यूआरएल यहां पर यूआरएल तो मिली है बट
क्या हम यूआरएल इ इक्वल टू कुछ मिल सकता
है तो हां हमें कुछ मिला है यूआरएल इ
इक्वल टू
शायद तो लेट्स सी व्हाट इज द यूआरएल इ
इक्वल टू ओके सो वी गट अ यूआरएल तो हमें
यहां पर एक मिला है यूआरएल मिला हमें एक
अब हम राइट क्लिक करते हैं सेंड टू रिपीटर
करते हैं इसको रिपीटर प आ जाते हैं लेट्स
क्लिक गो एंड इट्स गोइंग रिजल्ट्स गेट
यहां प हम रिजल्ट्स आ रहा है 200 ओके एंड
यहां पे रिजल्ट्स में वी कैन सी हियर
की ओके सो रिजल्ट्स में यहां पे हम रेंडर
करेंगे तो कुछ इस तरीके से आ रहा है
पीएनजी ठीक है यहां पे हम रिजल्ट मिल रहे
है पज इंफो आ रहा है गुड नाउ यहां पर हमें
यूआरएल के लिए जाना है यूआरएल कहां है
भैया यूआरएल सर्च करना है हमें
यूआरएल दो मैचेज हैं एक यह यूआरएल है और
एक यह यूआरएल है सो रेफरल यूआरएल फुल
रेफरल यूआरएल इज दिस एचटीटीपीएस अ देन
यहां पे jp.com यहां पे एचटीटीपीएस के बाद
कॉलन एंड स्ल स्ल को यूआरएल इनकोड करा गया
याद रखिएगा दिस एचटीटीपीएस के बाद स्ल स्ल
एंड कॉलन कॉलन को यूआरएल इनकोड करा गया है
एंड तब इसको प्रोवाइड किया गया है सो
व्हाट वी कैन डू यहां पे हम एचटीटीपीएस
वाली जो पार्ट है इसको यरल इंक्ड कर देंगे
कॉलन एंड स्ल स्ल को ठीक है ट्स इट उसको
हम य इंक्ड करके फिर ट्राई आउट मारेंगे
चलिए तो हम क्या करते हैं यहां पे डिकोडर
प चलते हैं यहां
पर देखते हैं
कॉलन पहले तो हम कॉलन को कर देते हैं देन
स्ल स्ल को कर देंगे
एंड इनकोड एस यूआरएल तो यह आ
गई कॉलन का हमारा ये आ गया तो यस सी बात
है इसको हम ऐसे ही देते हैं यहां पे हम
सिर्फ इसी को चेंज कर देते हैं jp.com जो
है ना तो इसको हम चेंज कर देते हैं jp.com
को वी कैन जस्ट डू
www.com डाल देते हैं ठीक है तो यहां पे
हम अपना पैरामीटर डाल देंगे राइट
google.com google.com एंड देन गो पे
क्लिक करेंगे लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग
ये आ रहा है यहां पे ओके अब एक काम करते
हैं ना अब यहां पे राइट क्लिक करके शो
रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर कर लेते हैं एंड यहां
पे कॉपी कर लेते हैं अब यहां पे आ जाते
हैं एंड यहां पे लेट्स सी इफ इट इज
रीडायरेक्टिंग टू google.com तो अब देखते
हैं अगर रीडायरेक्टिंग हुआ कुछ ऐसा तो इट
कुड बी अ पॉसिबल इट कुड बी
पॉसिबल ओपन डायरेक्शन नहीं हुआ तो कोई बात
नहीं है तो यहां पे कोई ऐसा कुछ
रीडायरेक्शन यहां पे आपको देखने को फिलहाल
जो है वो नहीं मिल रही है यहां पे भी
google.com पे रीडायरेक्ट बेसिकली नहीं
हुआ यहां पे आपका लोकेशन अगर देखें यहां
पे अलाव ओरिजिन जो है वो जेसी पेनी ही है
तो ओबवियसली इट विल नॉट वर्क राइट तो यह
काम आपका नहीं करेगा टार्गेट प चलते यहां
पे लेट्स ट्राई आउट दिस
वन ठीक है तो यहां पे यूआरएल मिला था हमें
ठीक है यूआरएल हमें कुछ नहीं मिला अब यहां
पे व्यू व्यू पे वी कैन सी द व्यू इफ वी
आर गेटिंग व्यू समथिंग या या या व्यू इज
इक्वल टू या देयर इज अ व्यू व्यू इ इक्वल
टू अगर करें
तो हां व्यू का हमारे पास मिला है तो यहां
पर प्रमोशन ग्रिड व्यू है यहां पे दिस इज
ग्रिड व्यू दिस इज ग्रिड व्यू दिस इज
ग्रिड व्यू चलिए ग्रिड व्यू करके एक मिला
यहां पे सलोन का सेंड टू रिपीटर करते हैं
यहां पे रिपीटर पे चलेंगे यहां पे एंड वी
कैन यूज दिस अब इसको ना हम इस पे पेलोड भी
डाल सकते हैं वी कैन जस्ट यूज द पेलोड
आल्सो जैसे मैं राइट क्लिक करता हूं इसको
सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देता हूं इंट्रूडर कर
देता हूं इंट्रूडर जाके यहां पे पोजीशंस
पे चलेंगे यहां पे क्लियर कर लेंगे एंड
यहां पे व्यू इज इक्वल टू मीडियम के जगह
पे हम यहां पे पे लोड डालेंगे अपना एंड
यहां पे डालेंगे लोड एंड ओपन डायरेक्शन के
जो भी पेलोड हमारे पास हैं वी आर गोइंग टू
एंटर ओपन डायरेक्ट ओपन डायरेक्ट पेलोड एंड
यहां पे हम टैक स्टार्ट करेंगे टैक को एंड
लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज समथिंग अनयूजुअल वीी
आर गेटिंग तो हम यहां पे स्टेटस 301 301 आ
रहा है अी बात है यहां पे लेंथ 33 837 है
तो लेंथ यहां डिफरेंट होना चाहिए अगर लेंथ
डिफरेंट हमें कुछ मिलता है तो मिलता है तो
403 आ गया तो नहीं मिला हमें कुछ 403 पे आ
रही है 403 पे आ रही है जितनी भी लेंस है
403 पे आ रहे हैं तो मैं लेंथ को शॉर्ट कर
देता हूं एक बार सो नॉट नॉट यहां पर आनी
चाहिए 300 लेंथ डिफरेंट हो तो 300 प आना
चाहिए जैसे एक ये लेंथ आया 301 पे 839 सो
देख लेते हैं शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर कॉपी
इट कुड बी कुछ भी कुछ भी हो सकता है तो
मैं यहां प करके यहां प एंटर कर लेता हूं
लेट्स सी इफ इट इ एक्चुअली
डायरेक्टिंग सो
ओके सो इट्स नॉट एक्चुअली डायरेक्टिंग
यहां पे आपका एक पैरामीटर है आईडी इक्वल
टू क समथिंग करके ठीक है यह पैरामीटर तो
है बट इट्स नॉट एक्चुअली डायरेक्ट ठीक है
चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां
पे
नाउ हम यहां पे क्या कर सकते हैं जो आईडी
इ इक्वल टू कैट पैरामीटर यहां पे है ना हम
इस पे पेलोड्स आप जाके इस पर भी वापस से
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं इस आईडी पैरामीटर
पे इफ यू वांट एंड यू कैन चेक आउट कि अगर
यह काम कर रहा है या नहीं कर रहा है
फिलहाल के लिए हमारे पास कुछ यहां पे आया
नहीं है तो फिलहाल इसको हम लीव कर देते
हैं
राइट फिनिश हो गई है ये चीज पूरी फिनिश हो
चुकी है तो मैं लेंथ को एक बार फिर से
शॉर्ट कर देता हूं 837 के अलावा अगर कोई
मिल जाता है
301 तो उसको ले लेंगे 37 39 है ये इट्स
नॉट वर्किंग यह वर्क नहीं करेगा ऑलमोस्ट
सिमिलर है तो आई डोंट थिंक सो एनीथिंग विल
वर्क
या शुरू के कुछ पेलेट्स को आप जरूर ट्राई
कीजिएगा इट विल बी गुड अगर आप ट्राई करते
हैं कुछ पेलेट्स को ट्राई करनी चाहिए जैसे
यह रहा तो सेंड सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी कंपेरर पर
भेज दिया
हमने इ चलते यहा पर अटैक वाली कौन सी पैनल
है कहां गई यह रहा इसको राइट क्लिक करिएगा
शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर करेंगे कॉपी कर
लेंगे एंड यहां पर इसको पेस्ट करके देख
लेंगे एक दो पलट को टेस्ट करने में कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है आप लोग को टेस्ट आउट करना
चाहिए ठीक
है तो हमने य पर किया एंड इट्स बेसिकली
व्ट इ डूइंग इट बेसिकली
नॉट गिविंग एनी काइंड ऑफ रिजल्ट्स कोई
रिजल्ट्स यहां पर हमें नहीं मिल रहा है तो
हमें यहां पे ये लेबिलिटी जो है यहां पर
हमें इस पर्टिकुलर पैरामीटर के लिए हमें
यहां नहीं मिल रहा तो इसको हम क्लोज कर
देते हैं एंड यहां पे याद रखिएगा कि ये
मीडियम एक पैरामीटर के लिए था ओनली इससे
बहुत सारे पैरामीटर्स है जो यू विल बी
गेटिंग ठीक है तो अब जैसे कि मैं मान लो
कि कोई सा भी एक पैरामीटर उठा लेते हैं
लाइक एनी पैरामीटर लाइक दिस काइंड ऑफ
पैरामीटर सो हम सर्च तो कर ही रहे थे तो
हम सर्च में एक आ पैरामीटर व्यू इ इक्वल
टू हमने देख लिया चलो हम यहां पे पैरामीटर
में
रीडायरेक्ट इमेज यूआरएल या लॉगिन इंफो या
कुछ इस तरीके से करते हैं आर यू आर एल देख
लेते हैं इ देर आर यरल है चलो य प्रॉक्सी
डायरेक्टरी वाली
है लेट्स ट्राई फॉर
फाइल नहीं है
इमेज इमेज का देख लेते हैं कुछ अगर इमेज
रिलेटेड कुछ है फबकॉन में यहां देखते हैं
इमेज आईडी इ इक्वल टू अगेन यहां पे इमेज
आईडी करके यहां पे दी गई है यहां पे एंड
यहां पे आपको सीएमआरई करके भी एक पैरामीटर
है दिस इज दिस इज काइंड ऑफ सम पैरामीटर तो
इट कुड बी पॉस इट कुड बी पॉसिबली
एक्सप्लोइटेड यहां पे इमेजेस यहां पे आ
रही है लोकेशन एसेट्स इमेजेस करके आ रहे
हैं अब देखो जब इस तरीके के आपके पास
पैरामीटर्स है ना इस तरीके कुछ यूआरएल है
तो आप इस पे भी ना इंट्रूडर पे जाके ट्राई
आउट मार सकते हो अपने से लगा के यू कैन
जस्ट गिव इट अ ट्राई तो अब जैसे आप राइट
इसको क्या करते हो राइट क्लिक किया यहां
पे सेंड टू इंट्रूडर कर दिया इंट्रूडर पे
आ गए यहां पे पोजीशंस पे आ गए यहां पे अब
यहां पे तो स्लश इमेजेस करके है तो यह
पोजीशन खाली है तो इस पर हम कर देंगे
टेस्ट एक टेस्ट पोजीशन बना लेंगे यहां पर
करके यहां पर ऐड कर देंगे एंड इस पर हम
पेलोड को अप्लाई मार देंगे तो हम यहां पर
लोड यहां लोड किया यहां पे यहां पर
पेलोड ओपन डक्ट पड कर दिया स्टार्ट ट प कर
दिया
लेी अगर कोई चीज मिलती है तो ठीक है यहां
पर जो लेंथ है 6186 है
ओके वी गट सम काइंड ऑफ लेंथ यहां
पर ठीक
है 404 है 404 है लेट्स सी इफ देर इ 30
एंड वी कैन ट्रा आट
200 करके यहां
पर
ओके तो य पर स्टेटस कोड 301 करके देखते
हैं य पर जैसे यहा स्टस कोड राइट यह हमें
एक मिला है वाइटलेस डोमेन ऐसे करके हमें
एक यूआरएल मिली है तो राइट क्लिक करते हैं
सो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर एंड वी कैन जस्ट
चेक आउट राइट वी कैन जस्ट गव इट चेक
आउट तो हम चक 4 नॉट फाउंड आ रहा य पे इसके
लिए तो 404 आ रहा है
तो लेट्स सी सम
अर एक बार रीडायरेक्ट इनेबल करके यहां से
देख लेते हैं यहां पर ऑप्शन में जाओगे ना
तो नीचे आओगे तो यहां पर आएगा ऑलवेज फॉलो
डायरेक्शन ऑलवेज तो मैं डायरेक्शन फॉलो
करवा देता हूं ए पेलोड्स प चलके एंड यहां
प स्टार्ट कर देते हैं ठीक है ना यू कैन
सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ फॉलो तो
यहां पर स्टेटस में देख लेंगे 301 अगर कुछ
आता है तो ठीक है अब
देखिए अभी तो हमारा ये चल रहा है व्ट इट
व्ट इट वट इट लेट्स वी गट सम काइंड ऑफ
डायरेक्शन यहां पे डायरेक्ट कर दे रहा है
तो इट डायरेक्ट टू
सम
नथिंग लेट्स सी इ इट इ डायरेक्टिंग
नो
नस सो यह माइट बी इट माइट बी नॉट वल्नरेबल
तो इसको
भी लीव इट एंड यहां ऑप्शंस पर चलते हैं
फिलहाल के लिए हम इसको नेवर कर ही देते
हैं एंड पेट्स प यहां पर फिलहाल इट्स नॉट
वल्नरेबल राइट तो हम यहां पर इसको हटा
देते
हैं अब हम यहां पर क्या करते हैं व्हाट वी
कैन डू सो वी कैन गो टू जेसी पेनी हम जसी
पेनी जी प चलते हैं यहां पर चलते हैं हम
यहां पर साइन इन पर चलते हैं एंड यहां पर
एक साइन अप नाउ का ऑप्शन है साइन अप ना ना
पे क्लिक करते हैं क्लिक करते हैं व्हाट
वी कैन डू यहां पर जब हम करेंगे ना यह
फर्स्ट नेम वाली तो हम इसमें एक चीज
करेंगे यहां पे हम एचआरएफ को यूज करेंगे
एच आरएफ चलो इस पे हमने ऑलरेडी यूज किया
हुआ है यहां
पे सो व्हाट वी कैन डू जस्ट कॉपी इट जब हम
बनाएंगे ना फर्स्ट नेम तो यहां पे यह डाल
देंगे तो यह डल ही नहीं रहा अच्छा फर्स्ट
नेम यहां पे यहां पे इन्होने वो
रिस्ट्रिक्शन दे र है अच्छी बात है यह
अच्छी चीज है कि इससे ज्यादा हम नहीं कर
सकते हैं सो इट्स ओके फर्स्ट हम य पर डाल
देते हैं मैंने यहां पर डाल
दिया
नितेश सिंह यहां पर फोन नंबर मांग रहे यह
कैसा फोन नंबर
है पता नहीं कौन सा फोन नंबर है
यह टेम मेल कर लेते हैं बस यह हो कि य ये
कोई यूएस का नंबर वो मांग के ऐसा ना करें
फिर हमें फर्जी नंबर निकालना पड़ेगा तो हम
य पर ल कर लेते
हैं हेलो हेलो कैसे हो ब्रदर तो वी आर
गेटिंग द टेमल
राइट
ओके सो हमें टेमल मिल गया पासवर्ड हम य
बना लेते
हैं एंड यहां पर हम क्रिएट कर देते हैं
ठीक
है बस व ओटीपी वेरिफिकेशन ना करते हो यह
लोग वव ट्रबल ट्रबल क्यों आ रहा है अच्छा
फोन नंबर की वजह से आ रहा है क्या
याय ईमेल आईडी की वजह से आ रही है फोन
नंबर तो सही बता रही है ईमेल आईडी की वजह
से आ रहा
है ओके सो लेट्स डिलीट दिस ईमेल लेट्स यूज
सम अदर
ईमेल किसीने टेस्टिंग के लिए मेल यूज की
होगी यह वाली
तो यहां बता रहा है कि भैया नहीं यह तो
ईमेल ऑलरेडी है तो हम कोई और ईमेल आईडी भी
यूज कर सकते हैं कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है सो
फर्स्ट वेट एंड सी तो यहां हम ईमेल आईडी
देते हैं लेट्स क्रिएट नाउ
ओके सो लेट्स गिव वैलिड ईमेल आईडी कोई एक
वैलिड ईमेल आईडी देते
हैं हा तो यहां मैं ईमेल दे देता
हूं चलिए एक ईमेल आईडी दे ही देते हैं जो
वैलिड है वही देते क्रिएट कर लेते अगेन इ
से चलो फोन का कुछ इशू लग रहा है मे बी
तो टेम यूएस नंबर्स
यहां से कोई एक फोन नंबर उठा लेते हैं इफ
र गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ नंबर
सो यह
रहा कॉपी कर लेते हैं लेट्स पुट इट यर
लेट्स पुट इट हियर लेट्स नाउ इंटर वैलिड
फोन नंबर अरे भैया वैलिड क्यों भैया आप
क्या चाहिए
क्या इशू क्या आ रही है यार प्लस प्लस वन
तो आएगा ही नहीं है
ना चलिए यहां पर
2512 6307
6796 एंड या इट्स डन नाउ सो अब जो है हम
यहां पर क्रिएट अकाउंट कर लेते हैं नाउ
होप फुली इट शुड बी
अन दिस इज सम काइंड ऑफ थिंग जो यहां पे
क्रिएट नहीं हो रही हमारी अकाउंट ठीक है
कोई बात नहीं यहां पे हम यहां प साइन इन प
करते हैं लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज सम काइंड ऑफ
थिंग दैट वी कैन
डू अ काउंट नहीं क्रिएट होगा तो कैसे कर
सकते हैं राइट फोन नंबर हमारा वैलिड आ रहा
है बट स्टिल अकाउंट इज नॉट गेटिंग
क्रिएटेडटेड हूं एंड यहां फोन नंबर डाल
लेते हैं फोन नंबर में क्या ही डाले यार
एक दो तीन च पा 6 कुछ तो डालो ठीक है ईमेल
आईडी में क्या ही डाले हेलो रेट हेलो
1.com
पासवर्ड डाल देते
हैं क्रिएट अकाउंट अब तो हो जा चलो अभी भी
नहीं हो रहा है ये सो काइंड ऑफ थिक है
इसमें अकाउंट्स क्रिएट ही नहीं हो रहे हैं
तो कोई बात नहीं हम वैसे ही इनको कर लेंगे
कवर प्रॉक्सी प चल लेते हैं टार्गेट प चल
लेते हैं एंड लेट्स ट्राई आउट अब हमें
यहां पे
ना इमेजेस मिले हमें इमेज इ इक्वल
टू कुछ मिला है क्या कुछ भी नहीं मिला
यहां पर लेट्स
सी जंप नेविगेट फॉरवर्ड लोड पाथ सारी
चीजें ट्राई आउट कर लेंगे सो लेट्स सी पाथ
इ इक्वल टू पाथ प कुछ हमें मिल रहा है सो
देन पाथ य पाथ इ इक्वल टू लैंडिंग पाथ इ
इक्वल टू ठीक है ओके सेम थिंग यहां पर कुछ
पाथ करके मिला है क्या सेम गोज इन द हेडर
ठीक है यहां पर कुछ पाथ मिला लैंडिंग पाथ
इ
देयर यहां कुछ मिला ना ना ना ना लेट्स
सी अच्छा यहां हम एक काम करते हैं 301 पर
चल लेते
हैं
ओके इफ देर इ 3 पॉट एक्स कोई एक स्टेटस
कोड है ये रहा तो यहां पे अकाउंट इज इक्वल
टू ट्रू ये एक आ रही है यहां पे इवेंट इज
इक्वल टू फॉर्म ठीक है ये एक आ रहा है
यहां पे क्या आ रहा है यहां पे कौन सा
रीडायरेक्ट काम कर रहा है
भैया
ओके देर इज सम रीडायरेक्ट्स
आईडी इज इक्वल टू आईडी इ इक्वल टू ओके
आईडी आईडी देयर इज आईडी आल्सो सो या वी
कैन गिव इट अ ट्राई ऑन आईडी हम आईडी पे एक
बार ट्राई आउट मार सकते हैं राइट क्लिक
करेंगे सेंड टू इंट्रूडर करेंगे इंट्रूडर
प जाएंगे यहां प पोजीशन प जाएंगे यहां प
क्लियर कर लेंगे एंड आईडी पे हम अपना
पेलोड जो है ट्राई आउट मार सकते हैं सो
लेट्स गो टू द पेलोड सिंपल लिस्ट लोड देन
गो टू दिस पर्टिकुलर
पेलोड ओके
एंड ऑप्शन इज
गुड गुड सो
स्टार्ट सो वी कैन सी नाउ 8
45 लेंथ है 301 मिलना चाहिए
सो वी विल ट्राई देखते हैं थैंक यू थैंक
यू सो लेट्स ट्राई ऑन दिस पर्टिकुलर इसके
बाद मैं एक और तरीका आपको बताऊंगा कि कैसे
आप ओपन डक्ट को उससे भी फाइंड कर सकते हैं
वो भी तरीका ठीक
है लेट्स
सी यह लाइव हंटिंग हो रही है तो जरूरी
नहीं है आपको वने बिलिटी मिल ही जाए बट
आपको अप्रोच ऐसे ही कुछ करने है स्टेटस
300 ओके
है 403 4033 तोय जीरो वाली है और कोई थ्र
वाली आ रही है क्या आ जाओ भाई कोई और थ
वाली हो तो आ जाओ क्या दिक्कत
आया नहीं अभी तक तो कुछ नहीं आया सब 200
200 आ रहे
हैं वेटिंग फॉर द थ्री वेटिंग फॉर द थ्री
थ्र की बहुत वैल्यू पता चल रही है ऊपर
डायरेक्शन में
थ इसके ये तो इस पर्टिकुलर के लिए आप सेम
टारगेट के लिए ना आप टॉक का भी यूज़ करके
ओपन डायरेक्शन वले एबिलिटी फाइंड कर सकते
हैं जैसे मेरा टारगेट क्या है ना मेरा
टारगेट
है jp.com ठीक है अब ये मेरा टारगेट है तो
मैं
google2 का यूज करूंगा मैं चार्ज बीटी के
पास जाऊंगा वयर इज माय चार्ज बीटी यहां पे
इन्होंने हमें एक अच्छा
खासा बढ़िया एक दे दिया था वेबैक यूआरएल
से तो मैं अब वेबक यूआरएल से इसी कमांड के
थ्रू इसको फैच करने की कोशिश करूंगा इसके
अंदर कोई इस तरह के कुछ अगर पैरामीटर है
तो उसको फिच करने की कोशिश हम कर सकते हैं
ठीक है तो अब सेम कमांड को अगर हम यहां पर
डालते
हैं नाउ लेट्स से नाउ लेट्स कॉपी द
यूआरएल अब यहां पर मैं यूआरएल जो है चेंज
कर देता हूं एंड यहां पर हमारा टारगेट
यूआरएल जैसी पेनी है कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल सी
कॉपी कर लिया और यहां पर मैंने पेस्ट कर
दिया ठीक है अब यहां पर हम देखते हैं इ वी
आर गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ
रिजल्ट्स वे बैक से जैसी पेनी से कुछ
रिजल्ट्स मिलता है हमारे अलग-अलग यूआरएल
से तो देख देते हैं लेट्स सी
लेट्स सी सो वी आर जस्ट वेटिंग फॉर द
रिजल्ट्स वी कैन गेट
सम मिल नहीं रहा कुछ मुझे लग रहा
इसको ओके इसको रिजल्ट इसके रिजल्ट को आने
देते हैं इधर चलते हैं अब यहां से हम चाटी
से बोलते
हैं आई वांट अ ग डॉक
द दैट
दैट टेक्स
अ टारगेट वेबसाइट टारगेट साइट
एंड सर्च फॉर
ऑल पॉसिबल ओपन रीडायरेक्शन
पैरामीटर्स यूजिंग इन
यूआरएल ऑपरेटर इन यूआरएल सर्च ऑपरेटर अब
देखते हैं यहां पे
google's सी देखिए
यह देखिए यहां पर इसने एक हमें ग डॉक भी
बना के दे दिया है जिसमें कि सारे जो
पॉसिबल आपके पैरामीटर्स
होंगे जो कि आपके किसके
होंगे ओपन डायरेक्शन के तो यहां पर टड कॉ
को रिप्लेस करना है तो मैंने कॉपी किया यह
पावर होती है यह आपकी पावर हैय तो कॉपी
किया टड कॉ में मैंने जसी पेनी डाल दिया
कॉपी यहां डाला एंड लेट्स एंटर जपनी कॉ ना
लेटस जस्ट ओपन इट जस्ट मैंने कॉपी किया
एंड यहां पर अब हम इसको गल करना शुरू कर
देंगे अरे
यार अब यहां पर हमने इस टारगेट को डाला ग
डॉक को यहां पर एंटर किया ग ड एंटर किया
तो जैसे पेनी के हमें रिजल्ट यहां पर आने
शुरू हो गए अब इन रिजल्ट्स में आप देखिए
कोई ना कोई यहां पर आपको पैरामीटर मिल
जाएगी जैसे आप यहां पर देख सकते हैं सो वी
आर गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ
पैरामीटर राइट राइट राइट यूआरएल में कोई
पैरामीटर कुछ ऐसे मिलता
तो यह देखिए रिजल्ट हमें मिल रहे यहां पर
ल ओपन ल द
रिजल्ट्स सारे रिजल्ट्स को हम ओपन कर
लेंगे एंड ल सी ल एनालाइज ठीक
है तो यह हो गया ग डॉक के थ्रू आपको ओपन
डक्ट के लिए कुछ फाइंड करना है तो यहां पर
फिलहाल तो कुछ नहीं मिल रहा क्लोज जैसी
पेनी में अच्छा यह भी आपको मिलता है य
देखिए ब्रांड आर प्लस डिजाइन प्रमोशंस इ
इक्वल टू आईडी इ इक्वल टू समथिंग मिली वी
गट सम
पैरामीटर्स यहां पे जेबीजी डॉट इमेजेस स्ल
कन्वर्ट जेपीजी टू पीडीएफ करके यहां पर आ
रही है ठीक है हेयर वी आर
गेटिंग एी टाइप इ इक्वल टू रेगुलर वी आर
गेटिंग दिस पैरामीटर तो हमें ये पैरामीटर
मिला टाइप टीएमपीएल जो भी टाइप इ इक्वल टू
रेगुलर है दिस पैरामीटर वी गट यहां पर
आईडी वाली पैरामीटर है सेम तो इसको अभी
हटा देते हैं यहां पे
कैट पैरामीटर है लीव इट यर आ टाइप
पैरामीटर अगेन वी गॉट अगेन आईडी पैरामीटर
वी हैव टेस्टेड ऑलरेडी दिस पैरामीटर वी
हैव टेस्टेड ऑलरेडी अगेन आईडी पैरामीटर वी
हैव टेस्टेड ऑलरेडी सो वी हैव अ न्यू
पैरामीटर दिस काइंड ऑफ पैरामीटर जो यह इस
तरह का कुछ पैरामीटर है तो इसको भी हम यूज
कर सकते यूज केस में ले सकते हैं फिलहाल
के लिए हम यहां पर अगर कुछ देखते हैं अगर
कुछ यहां पर हमें मिला है तो
यहां पे हम यरल को थोड़ा चेंज कर देते हैं
वे बैक यूआरएल तो है ना
भाई
www.jp
कॉ ठीक है और यहां पर हम टी कर देते हैं
और एक फाइल में या ऐसे डायरेक्ट व्यू दे
कर लो व्यू कर लो देख
लो ले
वकिंग कुछ इस तरह का ही गल डॉक हमारे पास
एक और है यह वाली गल डॉक यहां पर सेम गल
डॉक हमने कॉपी किया है इसको हम जाने देते
हैं अरवाज यहां पर हम आ जाते हैं लेट्स सी
इ
इट अब य देखते हैं इसमें कुछ क्या ये
फिनिश हो चुकी है लेट्स फिल्टर विथ द 301
301 पे एक ही है बाकी कोई 301 तो मिला ही
नहीं
हमें वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनी 301 3
3x बस एक मिला रो पे बाकी तो कुछ मिला ही
नहीं है राइट तो इट्स नॉट वल्नरेबल इसको
हटा देते
हैं नाउ लेट्स ओपन दिस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल
ये यूआरएल ओपन करते हैं इसको इंटरसेप्ट कर
लेते हैं प्रॉक्सी पे चलके इंटरसेप्ट ऑन
कर लेते हैं लेट्स इंटरसेप्ट इट राइट
रेगुलर
पे रेगुलर पे इंटरसेप्ट करते हैं इसको ये
रहा कहां गया
रेगुलर फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं
अ होस्ट इज डिफरेंट फॉरवर्ड
प आते हैं यहां पर हम सारा कुछ क्लियर
करके एंड यहां पर टाइप रेगुलर को रिमूव
करते हैं एंड ऐड करते हैं यहां प अपना पलो
एंटर कर देते हैं ए एंटर द पेलो सो वी हैव
द पलट और पलो पलो एंड स्टार्टक लेटस सी
व्ट इ हैपनिंग देखते हैं क्या होता है कुछ
तो
मिलो इ इ देर काइंड ऑफ रीडायरेक्शन कुछ तो
मिला भाई डायरेक्शन है क्या कहीं कुछ
डायरेक्शन तो दिख नहीं रही है
अब इसमें हम यह क्या कर सकते हैं हम इसके
सारे डोमस को कलेक्ट कर ले और सबको
रीडायरेक्ट x पे पास कर दे ऐसा भी कर सकते
हैं वी कैन डू दिस काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स आल्सो
राइट अब जैसे और ओपन डायरेक्ट टूल है ना
ओपन डायरेक्ट टूल है राइट तो हम उस टूल को
भी ये चीज पास आउट कर सकते हैं कैसे पास
आउट कर सकते मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं यहां
पे जैसे हमारे पास टूल है तो हम अब क्या
कर सकते हैं व्हाट वी कैन
डू एक पर्टिकुलर जब हम ओपन इक्स के गिच
पेज प चले जाते हैं ओपन डक्स तो हम कुछ इस
तरीके
से यू कैन यूज
दिस या तो आप यूआरएल को पास कर दो लिस्ट
ऑफ यूआरएल है आपके पास उसको पास कर दो तो
आपका काम आपका यहां पे चल जाता है या तो
आप पेलोड डिफाइन कर दो एंड पेलोड को
डिफाइन करके कर सकते हैं तो हम देखते हैं
डरे पेट प काम करता कि नहीं ओपन
रीडायरेक्ट
टेक्स ओपन डाय एंड यहां पर हम दे देते हैं
अपना टारगेट जो है हमारा जेसी
पेनी ठीक है हमने जैसे पेनीड कॉ दे दिया
ओके इट एक्चुअली वर्किंग नहीं इसमें ऐसे
काम नहीं करेगा ये सो वट वी हैव टू डू वी
हैव टू प्रोवाइड द पेल एक्चुअली हमें जो
पूरा वो है उसके थ्रू देना पड़ेगा तो हमें
या तो हम इसको एज अ टाग एक कैट फाइल एक
बना दे ठीक है ऐसे हम कर सकते हैं विम
किया हमने एंड हमने एक फाइल बना दी ठीक है
टारगेट टड t एकटी कर दी एंड हमने एंटर
किया आई किया और यहां पे हमने इसको पेस्ट
कर दिया jp.com को ठीक है वी पेस्टेड इट
jp.com ठीक है दैट्ची
टारगेट ex3 एंड यहां पे हम डाल देते हैं
ओपन रीडायरेक्ट्स
ओपन रीडायरेक्ट सेट ठीक है एंड यहां पे हम
एंटर कर देते हैं नाउ इट शुड बी वर्किंग
ऑन दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग तो यहां पे कुछ
प्रोसेसिंग जीरो हुई वन यूआरएल विथ 44
पेट्स यहां पे कुछ काम हुआ नहीं ऐसा इसलिए
नहीं हुआ माइट बी इट्स नॉट टेकिंग दिस डडड
थिंग सो हम यहां पे एक बार क्लोज करके एंड
इस तरीके से टारगेट ट्राई करके एंड देखते
हैं इ इट इज एक्चुअली वर्किंग तो यहां य
पे कुछ भी नहीं मिला इसको तो हम इसमें
क्या कर सकते
हैं व्हाट वी कैन डू
हियर फॉर सिंगल
टारगेट ये कुछ इस तरीके से हम पेलो डिफाइन
कर सकते हैं हम अगर हमें पे लोट चाहिए
हमें पेलो डिफाइन करना पड़ेगा कि इफ वी
हैव अ पेलोड तो पेलोड को डिफाइन कर करके
देन हम यहां पे हाइन के लगा के एंड देन
हान सी लगा के यह काम कर सकते हैं ठीक है
लेकिन वही है कि आपको एक लिस्ट ऑफ यूआरएल
जो है वो चाहिए होंगी लिस्ट ऑफ यूआरएल अगर
आपके पास है तो फिर आप जो है वो लिस्ट ऑफ
यूआरएल पे ट्राई आउट मार सकते हैं तो अब
यहां पे जैसे देखिए अभी अपने
पास लिस्ट ऑफ यूआरएल कैसे दिखनी चाहिए तो
कुछ इस तरीके से दिखनी चाहिए जैसे कि यहां
पे रीडायरेक्ट इज इक्वल टू फज कुछ किसी
चीज पे रीडायरेक्ट कर रही हो कुछ इस तरीके
से कोई एक पैरामीटर टाइप हो कुछ हो उस
टाइप का इसको यूआरएल चाहिए तो मैं एक
यूआरएल दे देता हूं जैसे मैं यहां पे ना
ये वाली यूआरएल पास कर देता हूं ठीक है ये
वाली यूआरएल हम यहां पे डाल देते हैं सो
लेट्स गिव इट अ यूआरएल तो मैं विम कर देता
हूं रीडायरेक्ट डटी एक्टी सॉरी
सॉरी मैं यहां पे विम कर देता हूं टारगेट
डटी एक्सटी यहां पे आई करके मैं इस
पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल को चेंज करके एंड जो
हमारे पास एक यूआरएल है इस तरीके से इसको
दे देते हैं कंट्रोल कॉलम क्य कर देते हैं
एंड यहां पे हम जो
है सेम टटी ओपन इंड डायरेक्ट्स कर देते
हैं एंड देखते हैं इफ इट इज वर्किंग सो यह
प्रोसेस कर रहा है यहां पे एंड अब यह
ट्राई करेगा टू फाइंड ऑल द पॉसिबल
पैरामीटर्स अगर कोई पैरामीटर है इस
पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल पे तो ये ट्राई करेगा तो
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे प्रोसेसिंग जरो
यहां पे 2 पर 3 पर एंड इट विल स्टार्ट
वर्किंग तो अब ये काम कर रहा है अगर इसको
कोई इस तरह का कुछ यूआरएल मिलता है जो हो
सकता है रीडायरेक्ट हो रही हो या कुछ ऐसा
तो ये आपको देगा अगर नहीं मिलेगी तो आपको
एरर जो है आपको प्रोवाइड करता जाएगा कुछ
इसी तरीके से ठीक है इस तरीके से आप लिस्ट
ऑफ यूआरएल पे ट्राई आउट मार सकते हैं आपके
पास एक लंबी लिस्ट ऑफ यूआरएल है सब डोमस
फाइंड कीजिए मैं तो यही बोलूंगा कि जितनी
सब डोमस फाइंड आप कर सकते हैं एक
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट की सब डोमस को फाइंड
कीजिए एंड उस सब डोमेन जो है ना वो जो सब
डोमेन है उसपे ये टूल चलाइए तो आपको वहां
पे लिस्ट मिल जाएगी यूआरएल की एंड देन यू
कैन डू अब इसका एक और तरीका है मैं आपको
वो भी बता देता हूं ठीक
है इसका एक और तरीका है डायरेक्ट वेबैक
मशीन प जाइए डायरेक्ट वेबैक मशीन प चलते
हैं लेट्स गो गो टू द वेबैक
मशीन ठीक है
वी केम टू वेबक मशीन यहां पे हमारा जो
टारगेट है मेन टारगेट है ठीक है तो हम उस
मेन टारगेट को यहां
पे लिस्ट करने वाले
हैं www.jacpcldce.ac.in
तो काफी टाइम से है यह तो तो इनका हम
यूआरएल निकालेंगे वी विल गो टू द यू आरएस
एंड ट विल विल
वेट अब हम यहां पे ना अल यूआरएल में सर्च
लगा सकते हैं वी कैन सर्च द यूआरएल तो अगर
मैं यहां पे लगाऊं इ इक्वल टू एचटीटीपी
ऐसे करके लगाऊं अगर कुछ हमें रिजल्ट्स
मिलता है या कुछ ऐसा कुछ या हम रीडायरेक्ट
ऐसे कुछ कर दे तो आपको यहां पे कुछ मिल
जाएगा जैसे हम यहां पे हमें आर ईडी आई आर
किया हमने तो यहां पे रीडायरेक्ट करके
हमें कुछ मिला रीडायरेक्ट यहां पे कुछ इस
तरीके से रीडायरेक्ट टम कुछ करके हमें
मिली है तो इट्स गुड तो हमें एक यूआरएल
मिला तो हम एक यूआरएल को ओपन कर लेते हैं
यहां पे देखते हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग सॉरी यहां हमें कॉपी करना पड़ेगा
इसको तो मैंने यहां पे कॉपी किया अभ इस री
डायरेक्ट यूआरएल पे मैं क्या करूंगा व्हाट
आई विल डू मैं यहां पे पहले तो इसको बंद
करो ये चल गया चल गया इसमें देख लेते हैं
कुछ 301 स्टेटस कोड हमें कुछ मिला है कि
नहीं 3 कुछ मिला ही नहीं यार
गेट हटाइए
इनको लेट्स रिमूव ट लेटस मूव इट लेट्स मूव
इट सो यहां पर प्रॉक्सी बंद है ना हा ठीक
है सो व्ट वी आर गोइंग टू ड व आ गोइंग टू
चेक द रीडायरेक्ट र सो हमने य पर पेस्ट
मारा यहां पर ठीक है अब हम यहां पर
बेसिकली जो रीडायरेक्ट पैरामीटर है
हमारी रीडायरेक्ट
टम इसको हटा देते हैं य पर डाल देते हैं
http.com वी कैन चेक आउट हियर
राइट कैमरा नहीं चल
रहा आई डोंट नो व्हाट इज हैपनिंग
गाइज ओके आई थिंक देयर इज सम
इशू कैमरा नहीं चल रहा
अब इसमें मैं तो कुछ कर ही नहीं पाऊंगा
बीच में शायद क्योंकि कैमरा तो यार चलना
चाहिए कैमरा नहीं चल रहा आई डोंट नो वई इट
इ
हैपनिंग आई डोंट नो वीडियो कैप्चर डिवाइस
एक्चुअली चल तो रहा है य यहां पर यहां तो
चल रहा है एवरीथिंग इ
फाइन आ डोंट नो वई इट नॉट कैपचरिंग र
कोई बात नहीं मैं कैमरा अगर हटा भी दू अभी
तो हट भी जाए तो कोई बात नहीं हटा देंगे
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है एक बार फिर से एक बार
लगा देते हैं इसको देखते हैं अगर चल जाए
तो ब आई डोंट नो ठीक है कैमरा नहीं भी चल
रहा आवाज तो जा रही है आपको स्क्रीन तो
दिख रही है
ना ओएस में मैं कैमरा एक
बार एक बार करके देखता हूं मैं
अभी तो चल रहा है आपको अभी तो दिख रहा
होगा
शायद अन पलक करके कर लिया यार एक काम करता
हूं मैं यहां पे मैं य पर रिमूव कर देता
हूं इसको लेट्स
ड अगेन वीडियो कैप्चर
डिवाइस लेट्स सी इफ इट इ वर्किंग
या सो अभी शायद काम अभी आपका कैमरा जो है
अभी शायद आ
जाएगा आई डोंट नो मैंने क्या सेटअप किया
था कैमरे में मुझे नहीं पता है
ओके ठीक है अभी रहने देते हैं अभी के लिए
फिलहाल के लिए वो रहने देते हैं जो चल रहा
है अभी आपको मैं दिख तो रहा हूं ना लिटरली
एक्चुअली मैं दिख तो रहा हूं ना आपको अभी
देख के बताओ आप लोग मैं दिख तो रहा हूं
आपको अब
ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात है तो यहां पे हमने
जो है हमने निकाला वेबैक यूआरएल से नाउ वी
आर डूइंग https.com ठीक है और हमें एंटर
करते हैं एंड वी कैन होप फॉर google.com
अगर कुछ मिल जाता है तो बट यहां पे कुछ
हमें मिला नहीं यहां पे टाइप अगेन ये
रीडायरेक्ट होके इस पे आ गया है यह आ रहा
है यहां पे उप्स समथिंग वेंट रॉन्ग द पेज
व आ यू आर लुकिंग फॉर इज नॉट अवेलेबल ठीक
है तो ये अवेलेबल नहीं है ये अच्छी बात है
यहां पे अब एटीपीएस कॉल goole.com
एंड वी कैन सी वी कैन इफ वी कैन गेट
समथिंग तो कुछ यहां प मिला नहीं य अब यहां
प मैं होम डालता हूं इ इक्वल टू डालता हूं
कुछ मिलता है तो नहीं मिले य पे व्यू इ
इक्वल टू डालते
हैं सो वी आर गेटिंग सम व्यू इक्वल टू
ग्रिड व्यू ग्रिड व्यू ग्रिड व्यू तो यहां
कुछ नहीं
है लेट्स ट्राई फॉर रिटर्न पाथ
हां रिटर्न क्लिक करके कुछ है यहां पर सो
लेट्स चेक आउट दिस वन लेट्स चेक आउट दिस
वन व्ट इज दिस एक्चुअली रिटन क्लिक ऐसे
करके मैं एंटर करता हूं नॉट फाउंड आ रहा
है
ओके ऐसा क्यों आ रहा
है तो मैं यहां पर इस तरीके करता हूं
रिटर्न क्लिक करके ऐसे यहां पर यहां पे गड
कॉ एटीपीएस कॉलन goole.com ऐसे करके डालते
हैं देखते हैं क्या होता है नॉट फाउंड
राइट सो यहां रिटर्न प भी कुछ नहीं है
पीएचपी करके कुछ है इस पर भी नहीं है देन
वी कैन कंसीडर सम
मोर पैरामीटर्स लिंक नेक्स्ट यूआरएल
रीडायरेक्ट कंटिन्यू
तो वो भी देख लेते हैं
लिंक यहां पर एक हमें पीपी आईडी मिली है
सो वी कैन जस्ट ट्राई आउट ऑन दिस पीपी
आईडी हम यहां पे जाएंगे एंड हम पीपी आईडी
जो है हम इस पर एक बार एटीपीए
कलन goole.com इस तरीके से करके यहां पर
डाल सकते हैं एंड वी कैन जस्ट चेक इट आउट
इफ इट इज रीडायरेक्टिंग बट नॉट सो जस्ट
लीव इट सो यहां प ये वल्नरेबल ओबवियस सी
बात है करेंट डिम करेंट ओवल कमो वैल्यू
डिम वैल्यू रोज आ रही है यहां पर कुछ कोई
ऐसी मुझे नहीं दिख रहा है कुछ ऐसा भी ठीक
है कंटिन्यू कर देते हैं कंटिन्यू न
एचटीटी एचटीटीपी देखते हैं यार एचटीटीपी
कॉलन
एचटीटीपी इक्वल्स करके देख लेते हैं यहां
नहीं है एटीटीपी कॉलन स्
स् लेट्स सी इफ इट इज समथिंग ये तो खैर
वही आ गया स्टार्टिंग
में आईडी देख लेते
हैं नथिंग तो आप मतलब वेबैक मशीन से
डायरेक्टली इस तरीके से भी आप अप्रोच कर
सकते हैं अभी जब हमें यहां पे रिजल्ट आए
हैं तो हमें यहां पे चा पेट्स प्रोसेस हुए
हैं कोई भी हमें यहां पे रिजल्ट्स जो है
यूआरएल वाले नहीं मिले हैं वी डिड नॉट
फाइंड एनी काइंड ऑफ पेलोड्स जो एक्टिव
हमारा काम कर रहे हो हमारे वर्क कर रहे हो
ठीक है तो आपको मैंने बहुत तरीके बताए हैं
अभी तक ओपन डायरेक्ट्स टूल का यूज करना
वेबक यूआरएल टूल का यूज करना इस तरीके का
आप वन लाइनर यूज कर सकते हो जहां पर आप
वेबैक यूआरएल टूल का यूज करके ग्रेप कमांड
से फैच कर सकते हो चीजों को पैरामीटर्स जो
है ना पैराम पैरामीटर्स फाइंड करने के भी
टूल्स को यूज आप कर सकते हो ठीक है उससे
भी आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो देयर इज अ टूल
नोन एज अर्जुन ठीक है ऑल क्रेडिट अगेन गोज
टू द क्रिएटर ऑफ अर्जुन
तो आप इससे भी क्या यह क्या है बेसिकली
एचटीटीपी पैरामीटर डिस्कवरी सूट है तो आप
पैरामीटर्स फाइंड कर सकते हैं इस
पर्टिकुलर टूल से एंड आप इस पैरामीटर टूल
को यूज करके भी एंड उसके तरीके से इसका भी
यूज करके आप ओपन डायरेक्शन लेबिलिटी फाइंड
कर सकते हैं तो इट्स वेरी इजी पिक्स
इंस्टॉल अर्जुन करना है एंड आपका काम हो
जाएगा उसके बाद इसका यूज केसेस आप देखेंगे
यहां
पे स्कैनर सिंगल यूआरएल इंपोर्ट टारगेट्स
तो इंपोर्ट टारगेट्स प जाएंगे यहां
पे तो यहां पे हान आई लगाना है अर्जुन हान
आई टड t एकटी यहां पे उसके रिजल्ट
एक्सपोर्ट आप इस तरीके से कर सकते हैं जो
भी आप रिजल्ट एक्सपोर्ट करना है जैसे आप
देख सकते हैं अर्जुन हान
य तो यहां पे आपको एंड पॉइंट जो है वो एंड
पॉइंट आपको दे देना है
दैट्ची करेगा आपको फाइंड करके चीजें जो है
वो लाकर देगा राइट
अब यहां पर जो टारगेट हमने लिया था यह
सारे टारगेट्स लिए थे इसको मैं हटा देता
हूं और यहां से एक कोई दूसरा टारगेट उठाते
हैं f.com करके
है हां तो यह टारगेट है f.com फम यह अच्छी
टारगेट लग रही है मुझे तो इस टारगेट को यू
कैन
यूज यू कैन ट्राई इफ इफ यू वांट आप इस
टारगेट के लिए भी जा सकते हो f.com एंड आप
इसको एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हो इसको एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए इसके जो भी है य रीडायरेक्ट यूआरएल
उसको ट्राई कीजिए फाइंड करने का आप इसको
वैसे भी वेब इसमें भी कर सकते हैं वेबक
मशीन में भी कर सकते हैं ऐसे भी फाइंड आउट
कर सकते हैं जैसे भी आपकी मर्जी वैसे आप
कर सकते हैं ठीक है तो जैसे वेबक मशीन में
अगर मुझे करना हुआ या ओपन डायरेक्ट से
करना हुआ लेट्स सपोज तो मैं सिंपली इसको
क्या करूंगा यहां
पे सिंपली आई विल डू वन
थिंग आई विल गेट ऑल द लाइक आई विल गेट मैं
मेरा अप्रोच क्या रहेगा मैं आपको अप्रोच
बता देता हूं मेरा अप्रोच क्या रहेगा कि
मैं इसके जितने भी सब डोमेंस है फाइंड
करने की कोशिश कर करूंगा कि मैं सब डोमेंस
को फाइंड कर लूं सबसे पहला अप्रोच है सब
डोमेंस फाइंड करना ठीक है सब डोमेंस फाइंड
करने के लिए आप टूल यूज कर सकते हैं
कौन-कौन सा टूल यूज कर सकते हैं सो आप सब
लिस्टर सब लिस्टर यूज कर सकते हैं सब अ
अ जो आपका टूल है एक सब डोमिनार करके सब
डोमिनर करके उसको आप यूज कर सकते हैं दैट
इज वेरी यूजफुल टूल सब फाइंडर यूज कर सकते
हैं जब आपने सारा सब डोमेन को गैदर कर
लिया एक जगह पे तो उसके बाद जो है आप
कोशिश कीजिए कि उन सब डोमस को ब्रूट फोर्स
कर पाए सब डोमेन ब्रूट फोर्स करने के लिए
आप बेसिकली यू कैन यूज अ लॉट ऑफ टूल्स
देयर आर प्रेजेंट अ लॉट ऑफ टूल्स आप उनमें
से कोई सा भी टूल यूज़ कर सकते हैं फिलहाल
के लिए मेरा जो गुड टू गो टूल है उसमें आप
एमएस यूज कर सकते हैं ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के
लिए उसमें आप ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए आप
वैसे सब रूट यूज़ कर सकते हैं बट वो आप उस
सब रूट और दूसरे टूल्स के भी पार्ट बन
चुका है तो आप एमस को यूज कीजिए दैट इज
वेरी ग्रेट टूल आप ल्टर एक्स यूज कर सकते
हैं प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी की जो ल्टर एक्स
टूल है दैट इज वेरी ग्रेट टूल आप
परम्यूटेशंस जनरेट करता है उसके बाद जब आप
टर एक्स को यूज कर लेंगे देखिए आप टर एकस
करके गिट हब सर्च
कीजिएगा तो आपको अल्टर एक्स क्या है
परमुटेड सब डोमेंस निकाल के देगा तो उसमें
से बहुत सारे इनवैलिड होते हैं तो उसको आप
वैलिडेट करना पड़ता है डीएनएस वैलिडेटर
नाम के टूल से आप कर सकते हैं जब आप जब आप
कॉमिनेशन बना ले बहुत सारे कॉमिनेशन बन
जाएंगे तो आप डीएनए वैलिडेटर करके टूल आता
है इससे आप वैलिडेट कर सकते हैं वैलिड सब
डोमेंस तो वैलिड जो जो भी डोमस होंगे
डीएनएस से वैलिडेट हो जाएंगे तो उसके बाद
जो है आप उस पे क्या लाइए जब वो आपको आपके
पास कंप्लीट लिस्ट रेडी हो जाएगी उसके बाद
आप चलाइए उसपे एटीटीपी एक प्रोब करने के
लिए एटीटीपी और एचटीटीपीएस सर्वर्स के लिए
जब वो मिल जाए आपके पास देन आप जो है उस
सारे यूआरएल को पास कर दीजिए किसके अंदर
में यू शुड बी पासिंग इनटू ओपन डायरेक्ट
एक्स ओपन रीडायरेक्ट एक्स में पास कीजिए
एंड दैट्ची
है यह सबसे अच्छी चीज यह आपकी जब हमने
यहां पे चलाया था हमारा टारगेट मैं आपको
दिखा देता
हूं ये इंडिड इंडिड वाली टारगेट पे जब
हमने ये चीज चलाई हुई थी तो इट वाज ग्रेट
आपको यहां पे अच्छे रिजल्ट्स मिले थे जो
कि एक्चुअली रिडक्ट करते हैं जैसे आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे ये एक रीडायरेक्ट हो रही
है जैसे ये अकाउंट जो है इस पे रीडायरेक्ट
हो रहा है तो ये एक जेनरिक रीडायरेक्ट है
यहां पे
ad.com यह एक इस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल पे
रीडायरेक्ट हो रहा है तो इस तरीके से करके
अलग-अलग जो चीजें है रीडायरेक्शन का आपको
यह बता दे कि कौन सा यूआरएल किस पर
रीडायरेक्ट हो रहा है एंड आप उस परे फिर
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं यू कैन जस्ट ट्राई
आउट राइट हां डीआर सर्च से डायरेक्टरी
डीआर सर्च से डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स करते
हैं डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए
डीआर सर्च यूज करते हैं इट्स वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल डीआर सर्च एंड एफएफ यूएफ
दोनों ही बहुत अच्छे टूल है आप डीआर सर्च
भी यूज कर सकते हैं डायरेक्टरी बस्टर डीआई
आर बस्टर भी यूज कर सकते हैं गो बस्टर यूज
कर सकते हैं या फिर एफएफ यूएफ करके टूल
आता है आप उसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं वो
आपकी मर्जी है वो आपके ऊपर है राइट
करेक्ट करेक्ट तो अभी जैसे कि हमारे पास
यह देखो अकाउंट ड डायरेक्ट के हैं ठीक है
यहां पर अकाउंट्स है यहां पर यह हमारे लिए
इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
पैरामीटर अगर कुछ मिल जाए तो हम उसको चेक
आउट कर सकते हैं यहां
पे सारे अकाउंट्स वाले
हैं सो नॉट ऑफ यूज अकाउंट अकाउंट अकाउंट
एच
ए
हम यहां पे है
h.c. रीडायरेक्ट हो रहा है इ ये इससे हो
रहा है हायरिंग इवेंट्स पे हो रहा है और
ये इस पे हो रहा है इवेंटस
सड ये इस पे हो रहा है तो इस तरीके के जब
आपको मिले जब रिजल्ट्स मिलते हैं इस तरीके
के तो आप इस पे ट्राई आउट जरूर आपको करना
चाहिए यू शुड बी यू शुड गिव इट अ ट्राई तो
मैं यहां पे जैसे यहां पे कॉपी किया यहां
पे आई जस्ट गिव कॉपी यहां पे मैंने पेस्ट
मारा एंड मैंने एंटर किया तो अब देखते हैं
हायरिंग इवेंट्स कहां जा रहा है तो ये इस
तरीके से रीडायरेक्ट हो रही है राइट तो अब
मैं क्या कर सकता हूं मैं कंट्रोल v यहां
पे किया मैं इसको एज अ टारगेट ले लूंगा वी
कैन टेक इट एज अ टारगेट राइट तो हम इसको
टारगेट लेने के लिए क्या करेंगे सिंपल सा
यहां पे टेस्ट कर देते हैं एंड यहां पे
बॉब सूट में इसको कैप्चर कर लेते हैं
लेट्स कैप्चर इन टू द बॉब सूट मैं इसको
अभी रिमूव कर रहा हूं फिलहाल के लिए एंड
इफ देयर इज समथिंग इन
द स्कोप
टारगेट पर चलते स्कोप पर चलते हैं स्कोप
में एक पड़ी हुई है इसको रिमूव कर देते
हैं हा अब हम यहां पर इंटरसेप्ट करेंगे
इसको एंड ल सी इ दे समथिंग तो हमने
इंटरसेप्ट किया ओबवियस सी बात है यहां पर
हायरिंग इवेंट्स को क्यों भाई टेस्ट नहीं
हुआ क्या हमारा
यह फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं
स्लैश टेस्ट को हमें हायरिंग इवेंट स्लश
टेस्ट हमें करने है राइट हायरिंग इवेंट
स्लश टेस्ट इसको हमें इंटरसेप्ट करना है
सो इंटरसेप्ट इज ऑन एंड नाउ वी आर जस्ट
एंटर सो देयर
इज
फॉरवर्ड यस तो आ गया हमारे पास सेंड टू
इंट्रूडर कर देते हैं इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर
देते हैं इंट्रूडर पे आ जाते हैं हम यहां
पे एंड इंट्रूडर पे वी आर पोजीशन
क्लियर एंड यहां टेस्ट को हमने ऐड किया
यहां पेलोड्स प गए सिंपल पेलोड्स में हमने
हमारा जो ओपन डायरेक्ट पेलोड है उसको ऐड
कर दिया ठीक है ओपन डायरेक्ट पेलोड आप
कहीं से भी आपको मिल जाएगा वैसे
google.it हो सकता है सो वी विल सी इफ वी
आर गेटिंग 3 पॉ समथिंग तो हमें अभी तक तो
कुछ पॉट में कुछ मिला ही नहीं है सो इट
माइट नॉट बी वल्नरेबल सो लेट्स सी लास्ट
लास्ट तक वेट करना चाहिए पता नहीं क्या
मिल जाए हु
नोज
google3 प एक समथिंग लाइक दैट कुछ हमें
ऐसे थ्री में तो कुछ मिला ही नहीं इसमें
तो या इस तरीके से हम चेक कर सकते हैं
अलग-अलग टारगेट्स पे अब मुझे ये बताइए कि
अगर टारगेट्स आपको दिया जाए आप टारगेट्स
खुद से लेके और उस पे आप लाइव ओपन
डायरेक्ट के लिए हंट तो कर ही सकते हैं
राइट अर्जुन टूल का भी आप यूज कर
लीजिएगा अच्छी अच्छी चीज हो जाएगी अर्जुन
टूल का आप यूज करेंगे तो देन यू कैन यूज द
टूल्स दैट आई टोल्ड जो कि हमारा एक टूल
यहां पे देखो अभी यहां पे बहुत सारे आ रहे
हैं यहां
पे दे इ देर इज या यह रहा एक नेक्स्ट वाली
जो आ रही है हां एक यह बार-बार आ रहा है
हमारे पास नेक्स्ट वाला तो हम इसको क्या
करते हैं करके कॉपी कर लेते हैं एंड हम इस
पर ट्राई जैसे कि ये आ रहा है कि नेक्स्ट
इ इक्वल टू स्लश पय जा रहा है राइट स्लश
पय जा रही है अब हम इस पर ना ट्राई आउट
मार सकते हैं लाइक हम इसको टारगेट ले सकते
हैं तो मैं य पर अगर सारी रिमूव कर देता
हूं
फिलहाल प्रॉक्सी इंटरसेप्ट ऑन करके यहां
पर हम इसको सेटअप कर लेते हैं एक बार देख
लेते हैं कुछ इस तरीके से सेंड टू
इंट्रूडर प चल देते
हैं ए य इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर देते इंट्रूडर प
आते पोजीशन प आते यहां प एंड यहां पे आप
देख सकते हैं नेक्स्ट इज इक्वल टू ऑलरेडी
यह मेंशन है तो मैं इसको स्लैश को यहां
पे इस पे वेरिएबल डाल देता हूं अब हम यहां
पे टारगेट्स को मेंशन कर सकते हैं तो पे
लोट्स को हम करते हैं यहां पे लोड कर देते
हैं एंड यहां पे हम पे लोट
को डाल देते हैं सो स्टार्ट अटैक एंड
लेट्स सी इफ इट इज वर्किंग सो यहां पे देख
सकते हैं 412 है एंड यहां पे 301 है तो
इससे कुछ डिफरेंट अगर लेंथ मिलता है तो वी
कैन ट्राई आउट राइट वी कैन ट्राई आउट इस
मिलता है
तो और सबसे पहले जब आप ऐसी चीजें करें तो
आप इनडीड का जैसे इड य इड की बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम है तो ऑलवेज ट्राई टू सी की
इनडीड का जो बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम है उसमें
ओपन डायरेक्ट जो है व एक्सक्लूड ना किया
गया हो ऐसा यह चीज देख लीजिएगा स्कोप में
हमेशा आपको देख के रखना है राइट तो मैं
यहां
पे ऑथेंटिकेट कर देता
हूं य शुड लवेज फाइंड द स्कोप्स तो मैं
इनडीड प आ गया अब मैं चलते हैं स्कोप में
आ जाते हैं अगर ओपन डायरेक्शन बाहर नहीं
होना चाहिए नहीं तो फिर दिक्कत हो जाएगी
ठीक है यहां पर आप देख सकते
हैं हा प फ में आता है इनके लिए तो यह
एक्सेप्ट करते हैं यूआरएल रीडायरेक्ट ठीक
है ना तो यूआरएल रीडायरेक्ट जो है वह यह
p4 में एक्सेप्ट करते हैं तो इट्स गुड
एक्सेप्ट करते हैं तो अच्छी बात है इसको
खत्म हो जाने देते हैं फिर देख लेते
हैं ठीक है
और मजा आ रहा है क्लास में लाइव हंटिंग
में मजा आ रहा है आप लोगों
को
हां चलिए तो यहां पर हमें ऑलमोस्ट हो चुकी
है
ठीक है अब यहां पर हमें देखना है लेंथ अगर
कुछ हायर लेंथ का 301 में कुछ मिल पाता है
तो लेटस सी इ वी आर गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ
ओके हमें जीरो पर क्या मिला था लेंथ 301
का जीरो लेंथ क्या मिला था हमें जीरो लेंथ
क्या मिला
था लेटस
सी रिक्वेस्ट 0 412 पर मिली थी ठीक है 412
प मिली है
गुड स्टेटस को 30 411
ओके इ गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑ हाई लेंथ ऑफ कुछ
ऐसा हाई लेंथ मिलता है
तो 450 450 ठीक है ठीक है ओके
ओके 600 कुछ मिला है यहां पर ये 600 कुछ
मिला है 301 तो इसको हम कॉपी करते हैं
राइट क्लिक करते हैं शो रिस्पांस इन
ब्राउजर करते हैं कॉपी करते हैं एपल क प
डायरेक्ट करने का आ रहा है लेट इफ इट इ
डायरेक्टिंग टूल कॉ और
नॉट न आई डोंट थिंक
सो
डायरेक्टिंग कोई ऐसा रीडायरेक्ट तो कर
नहीं रहा मैं रिस्पांस में देख लेता हूं
301 मूव परमानेंटली एंड इट इज शोइंग
लोकेशन यूजर लॉगिन नेक्स्ट एल कॉ ठीक है
एपल कॉ एमल कॉ एमल
कॉ ठीक है लोकेशन यहां पर आ तो रहा है
बट नो इट्स नॉट
वर्किंग सो यू कैन ट्राई कुछ हमें
रिजल्ट्स मिले थे अलग कुछ हमें अलग यहां
पे मिला है बट
या रिस्पांस में हमें लोकेशन तो यहां पे
एमल कम के आ ही नहीं रहे हैं सेम ओरिजिन
पॉलिसी है यहां पे इस वजह से शायद ना मिल
पा रही हो ठीक है कोई बात नहीं यहां पे
राइट क्लिक करेंगे शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर
कर लेंगे कॉपी कर लेंगे एक दो पलट जब भी
आपको मिले तो कुछ-कुछ पेलेट्स को तो ट्राई
आउट करना ही है आपको यू शुड बी ट्राइक कुछ
काम कर जाए राइट कोई सा काम कर जाए कुछ भी
हो सकता है नोबडी नोज व्हाट कैन हैपन सो
रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर सो आपको ट्राई आउट
मारते रहना है थोड़ा टाइम देना पड़ेगा बट
गिव इट अ ट्राई ठीक है हम अब सेशन के
दौरान इतना टाइम तो नहीं मिलता है लेकिन
हां वी कैन गिव इट अ ट्राई टू एनीबडी यहां
पे राइट क्लिक किया कॉपी किया कॉपी शो
रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर कॉपी एंड लेट्स ट्राई
यप्पा सो नॉट गेटिंग राइट ऐसा कुछ खास
हमें यहां पे मिल नहीं रहा तो अभी अपने
पास रीडायरेक्ट पैरामीटर्स होने चाहिए
सबसे बड़ी बात है जितने सब डोमस निकाल
सकते हो निकाल लो उसमें ओपन रीडायरेक्ट
टेक्स्ट चला लो उससे पॉसिबल तुम्हारे
रीडायरेक्ट्स जो है वो मिल जाएंगे जो भी
पॉसिबल एक रीडायरेक्शन हो रही है वो भी
मिल जाएंगे या तो आप वे बैक यूआरएल का
ट्राई करो वहां से जो भी रीडायरेक्ट
पैरामीटर्स वाले यूआरएल से सबकी लिस्ट
निकालो और लिस्ट पे जा जा के आप देखो कि
इफ दैट उसमें आप अपने लो डाल दो उस लिस्ट
पर जाओ उन लिस्ट को निकालो और पलट डाल दो
अब उन पलट पर देखो कि अगर वो पलट प
रीडायरेक्ट कर पा रहे हैं कि नहीं कर पा
रहे अगर पे रीडायरेक्ट कर पा रहा है ट्स
वेल एंड गुड आप उसके साथ जाइए एंड वो आपका
ओपन रीडायरेक्ट है नहीं कर पा रहा तो ट्स
नॉट योर ओपन रीडायरेक्ट ठीक है सो अभी
मुझे यह बताइए यह कौन सा टूल है दिस टूल
इज ओपन रीडायरेक्ट एक्स यह जो टूल है ओपन
रीडायरेक्ट एक्स टूल है मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी
बताया हुआ था आई थिंक आपने ध्यान नहीं
दिया
होगा यह टूल है ओपन डायरेक्ट एक्स ठीक है
सर्च कर लीजिएगा ओपन डायरेक्ट रीडायरेक्ट
रीडायरेक्ट नहीं है तो सर्च करेंगे तो
आपको इसका वो यूआरएल मिल जाएगा गिट अप का
लिंक मिल जाएगा ठीक है ट्स इट
google.com के ज आप कोई सा भी एक टारगेट
वेबसाइट दे सकते हैं ठीक है एनी टारगेट
वेबसाइट यू कैन प्रोवाइड अब मैं कोई भी एक
टारगेट वेबसाइट जनरलाइज एक टारगेट वेबसाइट
दे देता हूं एक जनरिक टारगेट वेबसाइट देता
हूं फिलहाल के लिए नॉट अ मेजर वेबसाइट
करेंटली चलो एक छोटा मोटा साइट कोई ले
लेते हैं लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक
चलो चलो
यड एड आ du.ac ले लेते हैं राइट दिल्ली
यूनिवर्सिटी की ले लेते साइट कुछ रिजल्ट
नहीं मिला
इनको यहां पर मैं साइट
में यहां पर मैं साइट में ड ए हटा देते
हैं यहां पे ये कोई वेबसाइट ले लेते हैं
जैसे कि मैं flipkart.com ले लेता हूं एंड
व विल एंटर यह क्या आ रहा है
भाई यह कौन सी साइट आ गई
है अच्छा कोई भी साइट आ गई कोई भी साइट है
यहां पे कुछ रिजल्ट्स हमें कुछ मिले नहीं
यहां
पे कुछ इस तरीके के आपको रिजल्ट्स मिलने
चाहिए मतलब मैं आपको एक वेबसाइट डिटेल बता
एक एक वो दिखा देता हूं एक ओवरव्यू दिखा
देता हूं कुछ इस तरीके रिजल्ट्स मिले ना
जहां पर आपको रीडायरेक्शन कुछ हो रही है
किसी तरह की तो मजा आ जाता है जैसे
टेंपलेट्स है यहां पे इट गेटिंग टू
रीडायरेक्ट इन सम काइंड ऑफ टेंपलेट्स यहां
पे कुछ ऐसा तो नहीं है बट स्टिल अगर कुछ
तो आप
google.in यहां पे ये भी एक रीडायरेक्शन
हो रही है इवेंट्स वाली इस पर भी देख सकते
हैं आप
ये रहा
[संगीत]
js.erb
निकल जाए राइट तो मैंने एक ये ओपन किया
रीडायरेक्ट हो रहा है इस पे है ना तो मैं
इस पे ओपन करके देखता हूं क्या है ये भैया
होम पेज लॉगइन अब ये कोई लॉगइन पोर्टल
निकल के आ गया राइट तो इट्स वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग मैं एडब मार्केटो एंगेज करके
ये कोई लॉगइन पोर्टल निकल गया मार्केटो का
जो कि रीडायरेक्ट हो रहा था इस पे तो यह
हमें निकल गया इड वाली जो है j ind.com वो
रीडायरेक्ट हो रही है तो हमें वहां पे कुछ
देखने को मिल सकता है
राइट नोबडी
नोज
मार्केटो सपोर्ट इड इनरिम review.com
यूआरएल यू कैन फाइंड यूजिंग
द द स्क्रिप्ट्स या एक तरह का एक वन लाइनर
का यूज़ करके वेबक यूआरएल टूल वगैरह का
यूज़ करके आप उससे फाइंड कर सकते हो य
इंट्रूडर और बब सूट के थ्रू फाइंड करना है
मैंने आपको बता दिया किस तरीके से पेलोड्स
का यूज़ करके कर सकते हो
google3 की क्लास जब भी होगी उस उसके पहले
तक आप ओपन डायरेक्ट के ऊपर इतनी प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे कि आपको ओपन डायरेक्ट वलने बिलिटी
फाइंड करनी ही करनी है लाइफ टारगेट में
करके एंड आप आ जाइएगा
जस्ट सी इफ दैट इज एक्चुअली वर्किंग एंड
इट्स रीडायरेक्टिंग टू सम अदर लोकेशन जब
हो जाए तो आप बिल्कुल उसको रिपोर्ट कीजिए
ठीक है सो अभी सब सभी लोग कर लेंगे यह बता
दीजिए
मुझे
ललित ललित मांगले सर हाय सर आई वांट टू
शेयर माय एक्सपीरियंस आई यूज टू वाच यू ल
बगवां वीडियो एक्सप्लेन वेरी वेल एंड ड्यू
टू योर टीचिंग आई गट अ जॉब एज अ एनालिस्ट
एंड गट हाईएस्ट पैकेज थैंक्स सर ओ क्या
बात है ललित इट्स वेरी ग्रेट टू हियर सच अ
न्यूज एंड मेनी मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशन ललित
फॉर गेटिंग द जॉब आई होप
कि आप अच्छा करें आगे चलके लाइफ में एंड
जस्ट कीप ऑन गोइंग जस्ट कीप ऑन हसंग ठीक
है ललित आपने लिंकन प अगर डाला है क्या
लिंकन प अगर आप चाहो तो डालोगे तो हमारे
को टैग भी कर देना ताकि हमें पता चल जाए
हम रीपोस्ट कर देंगे उसको ठीक
है ठीक
थैंक्स थैंक्स
थैंक्स ओके तो अब आज के सेशन को यहां पे
अ आज के सेशन को यहां पे हम एंड करते हैं
गाइस थैंक यू सो मच आप सबको यहां सेशन में
जुड़ने के लिए नेक्स्ट सेशन जो है उसमें
भी आप आ जाइएगा इसी तरीके से जितना ज्यादा
आइएगा हम लाइव हंटिंग भी करेंगे लाइव
हंटिंग थोड़ा ज्यादा करेंगे अभी क्योंकि
लाइव हंटिंग करने में मजा आता है चीजों को
फाइंड करने में मजा आता है तो ओपन
डायरेक्ट इज अ वेरी इजी टू फाइंड वनबिल तो
ट्राई आउट मारिए कि ओपन डायरेक्ट वनबिल पे
आप एक बार कर सके ओपन ड वन लेडी को अच्छे
से एक्सप्लोर कीजिए टारगेट को अच्छे से
टारगेट अच्छे टारगेट को फाइंड कीजिए जब
अच्छे टारगेट को फाइंड आप कर लेंगे तो यू
विल गेट य अ चांस टू गेट द बाउंटीज आप
बाउंटीज मिल सकती है आपको अच्छा टार्गेट
होगा तो तो धन्यवाद आप सबका एंड मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट क्लास में जल्दी अनाउंस करूंगा
मैं नेक्स्ट क्लास जब भी होगी तो आपको
चैनल को जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
whatsapp2 टू बिल्कुल आई एम 12 इयर्स एंड
इट इज बिग फॉर मी ऑल क्रेडिट गोज टू यू
ग्रेट ग्रेट यूडी टेक
अ बहुत अच्छे बहुत अच्छे बहुत अच्छे
थैंक्स डिजिटल वसेस थैंक
यू थैंक
यू चलिए अ ठीक है आप लोग ओपन डायरेक्ट को
ट्राई आउट फाइंड कीजिए मैंने आपको अलग-अलग
मेथड्स बताए हैं आप बस इतना ध्यान रखिएगा
ओपन इ डायरेक्ट फाइंड करने के व मेथड्स जो
हैं वह स्पेसिफिक मेथड्स मैंने आपको बता
दिए हैं उनका ध्यान रखिएगा ठीक है मेथड्स
मैंने आपको क्या-क्या बताए हैं आपको पता
होना चाहिए कि आई जस्ट टोल्ड यू कैसे आपको
पहले तो ओपन इ डायरेक्ट होता क्या है वह
बताया मैंने आपको किस तरीके से उसका
कांसेप्ट समझा दिया उसके बाद ओपन
रीडायरेक्ट को फाइंड करने के तरीके तरीके
बताएं जैसे कि आप टूल से कैसे फाइंड कर
सकते हैं मैनुअली कैसे फाइंड कर सकते हैं
बब सूट के कैसे फाइंड कर सकते हैं पेलोड
डाल के पेलोड का यूज करके कैसे कर सकते
हैं
google's का एंड ऐसे टूल्स को या वन
लाइनर्स का यूज करके कैसे कर सकते हो चैट
जीपीटी का यूज आप किस तरीके से एआई का यूज
अपने साइबर सिक्योरिटी जर्नी एथिकल हैकिंग
जर्नी में करके वनबिल को एगजैक्टली फाइंड
कर सकते हैं तो इतना कुछ हुआ आज के सेशन
में आज का सेशन ऑलमोस्ट 7 पए से 9:30 पीएम
ऑलमोस्ट ढाई घंटे का सेशन हो है गाइस सो
इतना जब एफर्ट कोई दे रहा है तो आपका एक
फर्ज बनता है कि आप मन लगा के और बहुत ही
सिंसियर जो है उस चीज को फॉलो कीजिए उसको
प्रैक्टिस कीजिए मैंने जितने वनबिल अभी तक
कवर कर दिए है ना लिटरली बता रहा हूं उतने
वनबिल को आप कवर करते-करते थक जाएंगे आपका
नहीं हो पाएगा मास्टर उन वाले एबिलिटीज को
तो उनको कवर करते चलिए नोट्स बनाते चलिए
एंड वी विल रीपोस्ट यू एंड ऐसे ही सीखते
रहिए ठीक है थैंक यू सो मच तो टुडे इज माय
फर्स्ट डे बट आई शो यू लॉट्स ऑफ वीडियोस
दैट वाज ग्रेट टॉपिक फॉर मी ओके अमर आप
आगे भी आते
चलिए ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट ठीक है
गाइस देन आज के लिए इतना ही थैंक यू सो मच
एंड हैव अ गुड डे एंड गुड नाइट आल्सो राइट
ट